Bamm, bamm, bamm, ba-damm, bamm, das ist doch schon viel besser.
Du bist gerade ziemlich laut, kann das sein?
Ich bin immer laut. Das liegt daran, dass ich so ein...
So eine durchschlagene Stimme hast?
Weil ich so eine durchschlagene Stimme hab. Ich kann mich hier ein bisschen runterriegeln und gleich das aus. Besser?
Ja, besser.
Ja, ich hab nämlich eine präsentationsgestehlte Stimme.
Ah, alles klar. Ich dachte, dass ich einfach nur lauter gestellt. Bitte? Ich dachte, dass ich einfach nur lauter gestellt. Und hättest du dich jetzt einfach ein bisschen wieder auf Normalmaß geregelt?
Ähm, nee, ich hab mich ein bisschen leiser gemacht. Ich kann dir auch noch lauter machen, falls du ein bisschen wichtiger rüberkommst.
Ja, ich möchte voll wichtig, ich möchte auch gerne noch eine tiefe, so eine Subwooferstimme haben.
Oh, ich hab so, ich hab Subwooferstimme, dann muss ich mal gucken, was ich da machen lässt. Sag mal was.
Bam, bam, bam. Ich hab mir, ähm...
Jetzt bist du so voll low irgendwie. Kommt schon, ich kann dir auch mehr Mitte geben, aber ich glaub, low bringt es jetzt ein bisschen mehr. So, was ist jetzt hier mit unserem dritten Diskutanten? Der ist weg. Du musst jetzt dein Mikrofon aufsetzen, Dennis. Jetzt siehst du nichts, ne? Pass mal auf, wir machen das mal für dich. Achtung, bleib einfach ganz ruhig. Warte mal, das Kabel ist zu kurz. Kannst du uns hören?
Also, nee, aber nicht über die Dinger.
Ja, kann ich. Du hörst uns.
Du kannst uns hören.
Doch, doch, doch, stimmt. Ja, kann ich. Du kannst uns hören, aber du kannst uns nicht sehen.
Kann mal jemand rasch ein Foto davon machen, bitte? Kann mal bitte jemand den Herrn fotografieren?
Ja, hast du ein Fotoapparat?
Ich hab ein Fotoapparat. Nee, ein iPhone hab ich ja gerade nicht, weil das ja gerade...
Was?
Ja, weil das gerade in dem Ding da drin steckt.
Ach so, stimmt, genau. Ja, erst mal ein schönes Guten Tag sagen. Denn wir nehmen bereits auf Ausgabe Nummer 5 des Mobile Max Podcasts und wir begrüßen alle Hörer aufs härteste, schärfste und herzlichste vor allem. Denn es sind wieder 14 Tage rum und wir haben uns wieder zusammengefunden und Max hat Gadgets mitgebracht, beziehungsweise ein Gadget, was wir letztes Mal, glaube ich, schon angesprochen haben, nämlich den, wie heißt es genau?
Cinemizer heißt das, glaube ich.
Cinemizer.
Ja, das ist so eine unglaubliche, das sieht ein bisschen aus von der Farbe her, als ob es aus den frühen 90er stammen würde, oder? So richtig direkt hier reingebeamt in unser...
Frühe 90er, ich will ja sagen 60er Jahre, das erinnert mich an so Designermöbel, wie sie beim Spiegel im Frühstücksraum rumstehen.
Ach, da kann man das auch sehen gerade.
Schön rot, so ein Ikea-Küchenrot. So leicht, wie kann man das denn beschreiben? Das ist so...
Mein erster Walkman hatte auch so eine Farbe. Ich glaube, es ist knallrot.
Auf jeden Fall. Es sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so eine Ladeschale für Handys und sowas ähnlich. Es ist ja auch, weil da steckt jetzt dein iPhone drin, sprich Dock-Connector.
Genau.
Und da läuft jetzt was, Dennis?
So 3D-Movies laufen da gerade.
3D ist nicht dein Ernst?
Ja, doch.
Was?
So Landschaften und so.
3D?
Die Schönheit von Heilberg. Da gibt es so ein paar Demo. Also man kann sich ganz normale Filme drauf angucken.
Und man kann aber auch spezielle 3D-Filme sich darauf angucken.
Also es waren vorhin zwei einzelne Bilder. Also das gleiche links und rechts mit zwei verschiedenen Kameras anscheinend aufgenommen und dann hat da irgendwas umgeschaltet und dann wurden die übereinander gelegt. Und jetzt ist jetzt mit dem einen Auge das eine Bild und mit dem anderen Auge das andere Bild.
Also man muss jetzt nochmal erklären, Dennis hat jetzt irgendwie so eine rote Space-Porsche-Brille auf, die an diesem Apparat angeschlossen ist. Das Ganze ist der Cinemizer von...
Ich will sehen, wie kloppt es aussieht.
Wir haben noch kein Foto gemacht, weil wir noch kein Fotoapparat haben. Hast du nicht ein iPhone?
Ich hab ein iPhone, aber...
Hinter dir. Du kannst jetzt nix sehen.
Ja genau, ich kann ja eh nichts.
Ah, jetzt wird das MacBook Pro eingesetzt. Lächeln mal, Dennis.
Ich kann nicht lächeln.
Bisschen tiefer.
Ich bin nerd, ich kann nicht lächeln.
Genau, wir nehmen jetzt nämlich Fotobuß. 1, 2, 3.
Jetzt hast du gerade so einen Kussmund gemacht.
Das müssen wir nochmal machen. Komm, guck einfach mal ganz cool irgendwie. Denk einfach an Motorräder. Machen wir noch. Gib ihm noch einen dritten.
Mit der Brille kann man übrigens überhaupt nicht cool gucken, glaube ich. Probier es gar nicht erst. Ah, obwohl, geht.
Absolut inkognito. Und wie ist jetzt die Experience?
Von dem Film hier? Also das mit dem 3D kommt schon eigentlich ganz gut rüber. Es ist halt ein bisschen, es kommt mir ein bisschen verschwommen vor. Ich weiß nicht, ob es meinen Augen liegt oder weil die halt...
Kann man das so scharf drehen?
Aber wie macht der das mit dem 3D? Ich meine, da muss doch der Film in einem speziellen Format sein. Was ist das?
Die machen einfach zwei Bilder.
Genau.
Also wenn man sich das auf dem iPhone...
Sind die beide nebeneinander und der trennt die dann auseinander und macht eins da und eins da. Weil das ist natürlich nur die halbe Qualität dann pro Bild.
Wie kennt er denn das?
Gar nicht automatisch das ist. Da muss man eine Taste länger gedrückt halten, damit er es bemerkt.
Ach so.
Also man kann da hin und her schalten zwischen den beiden.
Und wie sieht der Film auf einem normalen Bildschirm aus?
Da hat man einfach zwei, hat man 640x480 Bild quasi, ein bisschen breiter glaube ich, und hat da so zwei leicht verzerrte Videos.
In der Mitte geteilt.
Die in der Mitte geteilt sind.
Verzerrt im Sinne von die werden gestaucht.
Die werden ein bisschen gestaucht und man hat dann zwei Hälften.
Und die sind jetzt übereinander gelegt und jetzt sehe ich 3D. Das funktioniert, also das ist ganz gut.
Das müssen wir extra breit einspielen. Ich sehe in 3D.
Also ich...
Ich kenne extra breit nicht, aber ich kenne den Song nicht. Aber mach doch mal einen richtigen Spielfilm.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab ja nicht so wahnsinnig viele Spielfilme drauf. Ich hab ja nur legale Sachen auf dem Internet.
Also auf meinem iPhone hab ich die drei Klassiker. Und die drei Klassiker. Aber ich hab auch drei Filme.
Was kostet nochmal dieser Cinemizer?
Ich glaube so 350 Euro, wenn man die sich kauft.
350 Euro.
Die haben jetzt so ein Testpublikum sich zusammengewählt, da konnte man sich bewerben und ich hab mich da beworben.
Soll ich dir mal, wo ist mein iPod? Meine Jacke ist da.
Eigentlich wärst du ja jetzt mobil, aber leider war der Akku alle. Deswegen speist sich das Ganze jetzt gerade aus dem USB-Slot.
Ich hatte euch ja schon Verlängerungskabel angeboten. Mit dem Akku hab ich bisher massive Probleme gehabt. Also ich hab's richtig, hab ich den noch nicht vollladen können. Sowieso hab ich ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass...
Was machst du jetzt? Dein iPhone funktioniert wieder, Dennis.
Ja. Warum?
DFU-Modus.
Ach, was ist das denn?
Device Firmware Update oder sowas. Da muss man so einen speziellen Tasten drücken und speziell lange festhalten und speziell zum richtigen Zeitpunkt loslassen. Dann ist man in so einem Restore-Modus, der nochmal so spezieller ist als der andere normale Restore-Modus. Und zwar erkennt man es da dran.
Wir reden von einem Standard-iPhone 2.0-Feature. Oder gab es das auch schon?
Standard-iPhone-Feature, das ist ja ein Hardware-Aktivierungsgeschichte oder so, also relativ früh beim Boot-Vorgang. Und dann ist der Bildschirm noch schwarz. Da dran erkennt man, dass man in diesem DFU-Modus ist. Und dann musst du es an iTunes anschließen. Wenn iTunes dann reagiert, obwohl der Bildschirm schwarz ist, dann ist man in diesem speziellen Modus und dann kann man irgendwie nochmal andere Software einspielen, nämlich ältere. Die wiederum hat ein Loch und dadurch konnte ich irgendwie meinen Bootloader irgendwie downgraden oder was auch immer. Und jetzt habe ich wieder ganz standard 114 drauf.
Na, mit iTunes.
Mit iTunes einfach auf 114 runter. Dann hast du noch das 114, aber mit dem zu neuen Bootloader. Und weil es aber 114 ist, kann es irgendwie von dem Zip-Phone habe ich dann erstmal wieder benutzt. Obwohl man es ja nicht benutzen soll, weil der ist ja evil und so. Aber ist egal.
Ist der evil?
Hab ich doch schon mal erklärt. Der hat die ganzen Hacks von den anderen coolen Jungs geklaut. Der kann eigentlich nix. Jetzt ist es ausgegangen. Jetzt ist es ausgegangen. Er hat aber, er hat die halt nur geklaut und der hat halt Hacks rausgegeben, wo es noch gar nicht nötig war, weil Apple die jetzt auch kennt und dadurch dicht machen kann. Und da haben die ein bisschen rumgezickt in einer sogenannten Szene.
Also es läuft noch nicht offiziell am iPhone übrigens ganz.
Wir machen ja...
Aber wir müssen den Podcast doch jede Woche machen. Wir vergessen schon wieder alles, was wir gesagt haben.
Wir sind jetzt weiterhin bei diesem 3D-Brain-Gerät.
Was hättest du jetzt gerne hier?
Ich hätte gerne Blade Runner Final Cut.
So, dann müssen wir hier wieder umschalten auf...
Ja, muss das. Sonst glaube ich, sehe ich jetzt...
Ah, warte mal, jetzt hat er hier gerade...
Sonst trennt er die Bilder nämlich jetzt falsch auf, ne?
Ah, jetzt hat sich das Ding abgeschaltet. Das ist der Grund. So.
Also Max und Dennis formeln jetzt hier an diesen Geräten rum, und wenn es irgendwie live im Podcast voller...
Jetzt blinkt es.
If you could see what I have seen with your eyes.
Was zitierst du denn jetzt schon wieder? Ich mach heute mal den Unwissen.
Kannst du jetzt sehen? Oder siehst du jetzt alles doppelt?
Ich sehe jetzt was und ich höre sogar.
Wow.
Voll toll.
Und ist der Sound brauchbar aus diesem Apparat? Dieser Kopfhörer soll ja nicht so...
Na, ich hab jetzt natürlich noch unser Micro-Headset hier oben drüber, aber es geht schon.
Das Kabel finde ich ist zu kurz und lässt die auch nicht verlängern, ne?
Das Bild ist ja das Entscheidende.
Eigentlich sollte es natürlich so sein, dass man sich das in die Tasche steckt oder sowas.
Ja gut, aber wenn man abends im Bett liegt und das irgendwie experienzen will, dann will man ja nicht unbedingt jetzt noch sein iPhone irgendwie mit ins Bett kuscheln, sondern eher so nebenan legen. Also ich find das zu kurz. Zumindest sollte das mein Sohn haben.
Es hat einen Haufen kleinerer Macken. Also zum Beispiel ist hier dieser Lautstärke-Regler, der hier an dieser... Also man hat hier so eine kleine Kabelveranbedienung, das ist schon mal ganz schick, da kann man Play-Pause vor- und zurückspulen. Kann man zwischen verschiedenen Modi hin und her schalten, wo die Brille unterschiedlich hell wird. Und man kann lauter leiser machen. Das sind winzig kleiner Schieberegler, der ist eigentlich noch nicht so der Stein der Reichen.
Ich sag jetzt mal was zur Bildqualität, weil ihr quatscht ja ganz schön viel hier.
Ja, ja, stimmt.
Und zwar würde ich sagen, das Bild ist also erstmal schon mal kein Breitband, sondern 4 zu 3. Ist aber nicht so schlimm, wobei jetzt bei dem Blade Runner glaube ich ein bisschen was links und rechts fehlt, weil er hat keine Balken. Kann man vielleicht umschalten im iPhone? Ja, jetzt ist es okay. Breitbild geht, alles klar. Obwohl ich jetzt einen RIP von einer richtig guten Quelle habe, also eigentlich ist es richtig gut von der DVD, sieht es hier so ein bisschen nach Fernseher mit VHS aus. Da sind auch ein bisschen so Störungsstreifen drin oder Interferenzstreifen. Also die Qualität würde ich sagen, das geht in der Zukunft noch wesentlich besser. Auch von den Farben her ist irgendwie so ein bisschen matt alles.
Also die Farben kann man hier noch mit verschiedenen, also mit dem hier diese Modi-Taste mal ein paar Mal gedrückt hat.
Da ändert sich ein bisschen was, aber ich würde trotzdem sagen, dass es eher insgesamt so ein bisschen krieselt, wird wahrscheinlich analog wieder draufgeschrieben.
Ja, glaube ich auch, glaube ich nämlich auch.
Und es ist aber schon irgendwie etwas Cooles, finde ich. Und so kinomäßig, wenn man das so vergleicht, dann würde ich jetzt schon denken, ich sitze ganz hinten in einem großen Kino.
Also es ist eigentlich ganz cool, besser als auf einem iPhone-Stahnen. Obwohl du direkt von dem...
Ja, es strengt nicht so an. Aufs iPhone musst du ja so relativ... Also wenn es zu weit ist, dann ist es zu klein. Wenn du es zu nah ran machst, ist es für die Augen anstrengend. Weil wir wissen ja, die Augen sind entspannt, wenn sie ins Unendliche gucken. Und hier habe ich eher das Gefühl, dass ich, na doch, ein bisschen anstrengen muss, ich meine Augen auch. Aber es ist nicht ganz so schlimm wie mit einem iPod. Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass man so im Bett liegt, Kopf, also so auf dem Rücken, Kopf so Richtung Decke und dann einfach so da liegt und wahrscheinlich den Film nur fünf Minuten lang mitbekommt, weil ich sofort einschlafen würde in der Position.
Genau das habe ich mal ausprobiert.
Und war es so?
Nee, ich habe ein bisschen angeguckt, den Film. Hat auch Spaß gemacht.
Okay, war es ein guter Film.
Der Akku hat so lange gehalten, ja?
Der Akku hat nicht so lange. Ich habe es die ganze Zeit am Netzteil gehabt. Und ich habe einfach das iPhone-Netzteil hingepackt, habe es daran gehängt mit einer Verlängerungsschnur, weil da ist kein Netzteil dabei. Also ein bisschen besser könnten sie es schon machen für die 350 Euro.
Aber das ist auch eins der ersten Geräte, die das so haben, oder?
Das ist, glaube ich, eines der ersten Geräte, was man so kaufen kann, so richtig. Also was so Prototypen, Stadion, darüber hinaus geht. Und so coole Technologie ist es auf jeden Fall, aber in Detail ist es schon manchmal relativ...
Gibt es eigentlich für Erzeugen dieser 3D-Movies ein Plugin oder ein Tool oder sonst irgendwas?
Soweit ich weiß nicht. Also die 3D-Filme, die dabei sind, diese Beispielfilme, die sind so unglaublich, der absolute Hammer. Also den Film, den du gerade gesehen hast, müsste irgendwie so Heidelberg, Welcome to Heidelberg oder sowas gewesen sein.
Sah auch ziemlich alt aus, obwohl da noch Leute auf dem Mountainbike.
Was ist denn daran so unglaublich?
Das sieht wirklich so aus, wie die Brille aussieht. Also es ist nicht irgendwie ein Film, der jetzt gedreht worden ist, sondern der ist wirklich irgendwann wirklich...
In der Zukunft gedreht worden.
Ich würde sagen, vor 15 Jahren ist der gedreht worden. Ich würde sagen, dieses Produkt war vor 15 Jahren schon Markttreib. Sie wussten damals, dass es dann iPhones und iPods geben wird. Und mussten dann einfach noch ein bisschen warten. Ich meine...
Schwer zu sagen.
Also wie gesagt, dieser Rotton, der erinnert mich wirklich so an die untergehende DDR ein bisschen.
Aber nochmal zu dem Zitat von vorhin, ja? Das sagt dieser Roboter, Roy Betty heißt er.
Welches Zitat denn nochmal bitte?
Das sagt der Roboter Roy Betty zu dem Augen-Designer, den er trifft, weil er mehr über seine Herkunft wissen will. Und dem sagt er, wenn du sehen könntest, was ich mit deinen Augen sehen könnte, weil der hat seine Augen halt designt.
Ja, ja, verstehe.
Cooler Spruch. Überhaupt ist Blade Runner voll mit coolen Zitaten.
Blade Runner, jetzt kann ich dir folgen.
So etwas, was ich auch eingestehen muss, was ich heute nicht gesehen habe leider. Ich wusste das kommt.
Was hat er gesagt? Er hat es nicht gesagt, oder?
Ich hab's nicht gehört. Was hat er gesagt?
Du hast Blade Runner noch nie gesehen?
Ich hab Blade Runner noch nie gesehen.
Was? Das ist nicht dein Ernst?
Das ist kein Ding, das ändern wir. Ich hab den bei, du kriegst den. In zwei Wochen darfst du dann berichten.
Ich hatte ihn zu Hause auf DVD, als Directors Cut.
Aber ich hab den Final Cut.
Ich hab, oder Final Cut, oder ich weiß nicht, also irgendeine ziemlich neue Version davon hab ich. Du solltest dir den Final Cut anschauen. Ich brauch einfach die Zeit dafür.
Blade Runner ist halt nun mal wirklich ein Kultfilm. Also wenn du den nicht gesehen hast...
Ich weiß, aber ich hab ungefähr 80.000 Kultfilme noch nicht gesehen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Blade Runner ist der Kultfilm.
In der Liga spielt der nicht. Der ist schon noch eine drüber.
Den muss man auch wirken lassen. Ich hab den in der Jugend gesehen. Boah, geiler Actionfilm. Ich hab den ein paar Jahre später gesehen. Es geht ja um Zukunftsgeschichten und so. Wer bin ich und wo komm ich her? Und dann guckst du ihn nochmal und schon ist wieder alles anders. Den kann man in seinem Leben öfter sehen.
Der letzte, über den ich das gehört habe, war Hermann Hesse. Ich bin niemals über Seite 10 hinausgekommen.
Naja, ich kopier den mal und dann...
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich hab sogar alles, das volle Programm zuhause. Ich wollte bloß mal auf eine ruhige Minute warten. Aber ich hab wirklich so einige Kultfilme im Leben noch nicht gesehen.
Aber so abschließend zu diesem Produkt, würde ich sagen, das ist ein guter Start. Aber es muss irgendwie noch besser werden. Und ein bisschen größer hätte ich es gerne so. Also dass ich im Kino mehr so in der Mitte sitze und nicht so weit hinten. Und dann könnte ich mir das schon cool vorstellen zum Filme gucken.
Also hältst du es ganz gerne auch mit der See-Through-Option? Am besten vorher noch eine Kamera, damit man so einen Slider hat, wo man die Realität reinmixen kann?
Auf so eine ganz lange Sicht, so 20 Jahre, dann hätte ich es gerne so wie der Terminator, der durch die Gegend läuft und so See-Through und so Overlays. Und zum Beispiel auch der mir im Dunkeln gleich die Raumkanten nochmal mit so einem Neon-Grün, damit er genau, also dass du deinen Raum so in Wireframe nochmal siehst.
Ja, so überlagert. Mit so kleinen Pieptönen, wenn er dir irgendwie so die Attacks runterscrollt.
Wer auch immer uns jetzt so hört, Dennis bitte niemals so ein Ding geben. Ich hab Angst davor, wenn Dennis hier als der Terminator aufschlägt. Gerade so wie er jetzt aussieht mit Mikro und Drille und allem Pieperpo.
Und der mir gleich irgendwie den Opposite Sex anzeigt in meinem Beuteschema.
Ich hab mir mal genau angeschaut.
Erkennst du den nicht selber?
Doch, aber dann fällt es mir leichter.
Die haben ja manchmal im Hintergrund... Terahearts.
Du brauchst noch einen Terahearts-Scanner.
Was ist das?
Na, Terahearts.
Achso, der durch die Klamotten durchgucken kann.
Ja, nee, das kann man auch später machen.
Ich hab mir mal angeschaut, was beim Terminator tatsächlich über dem Bildschirm läuft.
Also was da immer so steht und so?
Ja, was da rund das crawlt?
Nö.
65002 Assembler Code. Das hatten sie nix anderes?
Jetzt wird der Tim gleich erzählen, dass er da schon ein Assembler programmiert hat und so.
Ach Quatsch, das erzählst du ja dann schon. Wer nicht?
Ich muss das noch mit Peek and Poke in den Speicher hauen.
Aber stimmt, 1984. Stimmt, der ist von 1984.
Eigentlich noch einmal ein Movie. Der Film, den müsst ihr eigentlich nochmal neu machen. Weil er ist gar nicht schlecht. Auch die Story, also ich finde immer Story, die sich selbst einholen, die finde ich irgendwie cool. Genau wie mit Planet der Affen.
Ja, nochmal neu machen, aber wen willst du denn bitte Arnold Schwarzenegger spielen lassen?
Na niemanden.
Ach so, du meinst, man nimmt einfach Arnold und macht den irgendwie mit CGI komplett nach?
Kann aber anders aussehen.
Ist nur teuer. Na ja, geht ja nicht. Kann sich doch kein Mensch vorstellen, dass der Terminator anders aussieht als Arnold.
Das ist das Cooleste am Terminator war doch...
Der fällt in der ersten Sekunde irgendwo rein, hat kein Gesicht mehr, kriegt ein neues Gesicht fertig.
Das Cooleste am Terminator war, als er vom LKW überfahren wird, alles brennt und er plötzlich als Skelett wieder aufsteht mit den roten Augen. Es gibt nichts mehr. Den ganzen Rest braucht man nicht Fleisch. Und wer braucht denn Fleisch? Du brauchst nur das Skelett mit den Motoren dran. Das ist das Gruseligste überhaupt. Als ich den Film geguckt habe, ich fand das als er plötzlich wieder aufstand, dachte ich schon, oh shit.
Oder mit einer roten Cinemizer-Pille. Das sieht auch ziemlich gruselig aus.
Ich hab's ja Gott sei Dank noch nicht gesehen. Willst du mir nach der Sendung angucken, sonst bin ich vielleicht geschockt und kann die ganze Sendung lang nichts mehr sagen.
Ja, jetzt haben wir ein schönes Produkt vorgestellt. Und sind wir jetzt warm? Jetzt können wir ja mal anfangen hier mit unserem Podcast, oder? Ach so. Den nehmen wir nämlich schon auf seit einer Viertelstunde.
Ja klar, selbstverständlich.
Länger schon.
So, ich setz mal die Brille ab, sonst muss ich ihn noch irgendwie gleich Kino bezahlen.
Jaja, genau.
Ich zieh mal einfach gerade raus, ne?
Zieh raus.
Nicht schlecht.
Ach so, jetzt noch ein Kabel irgendwie?
Jetzt ist sie frei.
So, jetzt lassen wir sie nochmal unter dem Kabel durch. Und schon ist alles bestens.
Also in zwei, drei Jahren werden die Nachfolgegeräte davon kommen. Dann kann das schon ganz schick werden.
Ich hab jetzt irgendwo neulich gerade was darüber gelesen, dass dann so mit den ersten OLED-Displays da drinnen, weil da sind die nochmal, die sind schonmal ziemlich fett hier, das Ding.
Ich muss ja jetzt auch nochmal reinkieken.
Kiek da nochmal hin.
Oder damit ich ne Vorstellung davon habe.
Und ich denke, die werden es vom Prinzip auch ändern. Die werden es bestimmt irgendwann so machen, dass da so ein kleiner Laser ist, der direkt auf dein Auge schießt. Da hab ich schon letztens was von gelesen. Ja, haben die auch geschrieben, dass wenn was schief geht...
Muss man Marketing-Technisch ein bisschen anders vermitteln.
Ja, wenn was schief geht, dass du dir in den Augen wegschießt. Aber das kann man ja auch physikalisch irgendwie begrenzen. Aber dafür ist das Bild super. Genau.
Aber stimmt, das ist wirklich ganz schön... Also ich hab jetzt die Brille auf. Hört man mich überhaupt noch?
Ich hör mich irgendwie sehr wenig. Ja, jetzt hört man dich.
Du siehst wirklich anders aus.
Stimmt, jetzt weiß ich, was du meinst.
Ich mach noch mal ein Foto. Ich glaube, das könnte sich mal ganz gut auswirken, wenn ich mal dringend jemanden erpressen muss oder sowas.
Das hat wirklich so dieses Kino-letzte-Reihe-Feeling. Und zwar so kleines Schachtelkino. So ein kleines 100-Personen-Kino.
Auf jeden Fall sitzt es so weit hinten, so vom Gefühl. Also es könnte schon noch ein bisschen näher rankommen.
Und wenn man den Sound nicht hört...
Du hast gerade ganz leise.
Aber ich glaube, ich hab das jetzt auch gar nicht richtig auf.
Da muss man normalerweise noch die Kopfhörer runter.
Ich hatte ein bisschen Sound.
Nee, das reicht mir jetzt auch. Ich will ja nur wissen, wie es aussieht. Aber stimmt, es sind so komische Streifen drauf. Der hat so ein bisschen analoge Verluste und so. Aber es ist in der Tat angenehm. Angenehmer als ich jetzt gedacht hätte, dass es sein könnte. Stimmt, das ist echt ziemlich cool.
Und weil wir eine Macintosh-Sendung sind hier, wir haben mein iPhone reingeschickt und es ging sofort. Also es ist kein Fummelkram oder so.
Nein, ein bisschen Fummelkram ist es schon. Wenn man es ran schließt in den USB, muss man es trotzdem erstmal einschalten.
Jetzt mach ich hier voll das positive Ding und dann macht er mir das gleich wieder kaputt.
Ich hab da einfach schon ein bisschen Erfahrung mit dem Ding. Es war relativ simpel auf jeden Fall.
Es ist nicht die Schlussszene.
Nein, aber es geht so gegen's Ende. Es wird gerade so ein bisschen, du weißt schon, rutschgehauer und so. Der Film ist wirklich der Hammer. Sollte es tatsächlich unter unseren Hörern Leute geben, die die Play-Droner noch nicht gesehen haben.
Wann kommt er hier vorbei? Ich guck ihm dennächst.
Dann müsst ihr einfach mal sofort in die Piratenbucht fahren. Ihr wisst schon. Gut, jetzt können wir nochmal überlegen. Jungs, ich hab nochmal drüber nachgedacht mit dem Titel. Ich werd ja ein bisschen verrückt irgendwie, wenn man so diese Titel, wenn ich mir so vorstelle, wir machen 30, 40 Sendungen und jeder Titel jeder Sendung ist wirklich immer nur so die Liste der Themen. Ist ein bisschen uncool, oder?
Was hättest du denn lieber?
Keine Ahnung, ich hab ja gesagt, dass ich ein bisschen unentschlossen bin. Auf der einen Seite gibt es das Praktische für den iPod, sonst haben sich auch Leute im Blog dafür ausgesprochen, dass man das so macht. Aber andere waren halt der Meinung, dass die letzte Sendung, dass es eigentlich ein taktischer Fehler war, sie nicht Star-Fit-Expander muss sterben, heißt.
Das find ich auch.
Und das ist nämlich auch das, worüber ich nachgedacht habe. Die Sendung heißt nämlich jetzt nicht Star-Fit-Expander muss sterben. Und ehrlich gesagt, könntest du dich daran erinnern, wie ich sie genannt habe?
Nö, aber bei Star-Fit-Expander auch nicht gewusst.
Ja, aber wenn du wüsstest jetzt, dass sie Star-Fit-Expander muss sterben gehießen hat, dann könntest du dich daran erinnern. Aber man kann sich nicht daran erinnern, dass sie irgendwie iPhone, Thema 2, Thema 3, 4 heißt.
Das ist immer die Sendung.
Genau, dann fangst du immer mit einem fucking iPhone an, und deswegen ist es scheiße. Ich würde sagen, wenn wir für diese Sendung wieder einen guten Titel finden, dann nehmen wir den. Dann machen wir das so. Und dann bedenne ich auch noch die anderen oben, weil dann höre ich sie mir nämlich echt alle nochmal an. Oder wir lassen abstimmen darüber, wie die Sendung heißt.
Weil die Leute, die dann erst hören müssen, bevor sie sagen können, wie sie heißen soll, aber die brauchen die Information ja, bevor sie sie hören, oder wie?
Nein, die Sendungen, die schon draußen sind, brauchen nachträglich einen Titel. Weil für die vierte ist es klar, die erste hat schon einen, also sind's nur zwei. Und ich denke, bei zwei Sendungen ist das schon noch zu leisten.
Ja klar. Dann brauchen wir jetzt erst mal einen Arbeitstitel.
Wir brauchen erst mal einen Polling Plugin fürs Blog. Hast du mal geguckt?
Ich hab bisher noch nicht geguckt, um ehrlich zu sein.
Aber du machst das mal.
Aber ich mach das mal.
Das ist doch schön.
Super.
Das ist toll, wenn man irgendwie Administratoren unter... Ich hab übrigens auch ein neues Gadget, ihr habt's schon gesehen. Ich hab mir ein Mac Mini gekauft, ich hab's tatsächlich getan. Es war ein Kauf im Affekt.
Also den Mac Mini selbst hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Ja, der war schön versteckt hinter der Glasscheibe.
Aber ich hab das Bild auf dem Fernseher gesehen.
Das war ein bisschen britzel, britzel, britzelmäßig. Das liegt daran, dass es mit so einem etwas wackeligen Video-Kabel angeschlossen ist und der Fernseher ist halt schon gut 20 Jahre alt.
Dafür war es aber echt lockier, fand ich.
Das finde ich ideal, wenn man sich da so... Wenn man sich da so rauschiges Video anschaut, ist das eigentlich ganz okay.
Mit anderen Worten, der Kauf eines neuen Fernsehers ist schon eingeplant?
Ich kann mich so schlecht zu etwas durchringen, weil dieser ganze Fernsehermarkt ist ein bisschen bekloppt.
Es gibt keine Fernseher mehr.
Doch, doch.
Jetzt wird es ein LCD-Panel.
Na ja, wenn es nur LCD-Panels wären, hätte ich mir schon längst eingekauft. Aber dadurch, dass da immer noch so ein Fernseher mit drin ist, kostet das dann halt noch mal extra.
Aber der Junior, der kostet doch nicht die Welt, oder? Der da drin steckt.
Ja, aber es ist halt irgendwie alles Mögliche. Blah, Fernsehtechnologie, Skat, Stecker und so. Ich brauch das alles nicht. Ich brauch halt nicht nur ein Display. Eigentlich würd ich mir lieber so ein Apple-Display hinstellen, aber obwohl die keinen Fernseher drin haben, kosten sie irgendwie das Dreifache.
Krieg erst mal raus, ob man die überhaupt vernünftig rangeht. Ich hab mal irgendwie so ein 30 Zoll Cinema-Display. Das ließ ich damals nicht an den aktuellen Rechnern betreiben.
Ich hab so ein 23 Zoll zu Hause und das ist voll toll.
Als Fernseher sozusagen. Ja eben, also als das, was andere Leute als Fernseher haben. Für ein Rechner.
Aber ich hab trotzdem schon ewig keine Movies mehr geguckt.
Ja, weil ich bin natürlich auch hin und her gerissen. Andererseits, wenn ich mal wirklich die Zeit finde, da mal irgendwie Cinema zu gucken, dann gucke ich halt auch gleich richtig Cinema und dann könnte ich mir auch gleich einen Beamer zulegen. Also für die paar Male, wo ich dieses Teil anschalte, könnte ich dann auch wirklich einen Beamer nehmen. Und beim Beamer wiederum kommen wir zu dieser Schwierigkeit. Das sind unsere Probleme in unserer Luxus-Gesellschaft. Kaufe ich mir einen großen Fernseher oder kaufe ich mir einen Beamer? Anstatt, dass wir uns über die Probleme der Welt unterhalten, ist es so ein Kack, der uns...
Kaufe doch einfach beides und spende ein bisschen was! Oh no!
Du meinst, kaufe doch eins und beides und spende?
So ein C und 2 Ausgleich, ne? Ja und diese Fernseherkosten, die schlucken auch echt mächtig Strom. Auf die großen Teile?
Auf die LCD-Dinger?
Der Beamer auch.
Na ja, die machen so 300 Watt in der Regel. Also ich hab welche gesehen mit 240 Watt beim 46 Zoll Bildschirm, das war schon so das Beste.
46 Zoll, das ist aber schon monströs groß, oder?
Na ja, wenn ich mir nach 20 Jahren mal einen Fernseher kaufe, dann muss er ja auch schon größer sein als das, was ich jetzt hab. Ich hab jetzt so einen 29 Zoll 4 zu 3. Und das war damals einfach The Hype. Also ich bin 4000 Mark gekostet, keine Ahnung, warum ich so viel Geld ausgegeben hab. Klingt super, Sony Acoustic Line, macht richtig Wumm. Aber ist halt jetzt ein bisschen durch, weil Apple TV könnte ich da zum Beispiel nicht dran betreiben, weil da einfach der passende Anspruch fehlt. Kein Digital, kein Komponent und so. Tja, so ist das. Das ist aber jetzt auch nicht so wichtig. Wichtiger ist, ich hab diesen Mac Mini installiert und hab dann mir mal eine Raubkopie von US-10-Server draufgetan, um mal zu gucken, wie das so ist. Ja, das ist dabei.
Das ist auch beim Server dabei.
Ja, mir ist sowieso noch nicht ganz klar, was beim Server nicht dabei ist. Du hast halt so ein bisschen anderes Sharing-Layout, weil das natürlich da auf viele Dienste ausgelegt ist. Und dann gibt es so diese ganze Batterie von Administrationstools, die so mehr oder weniger guttun. Mir ist bisher noch nicht gelungen, den iCalendar-Server zum Laufen zu kriegen, weswegen ich mir das ja eigentlich vordergründig gekauft habe.
Das ist nicht ganz so trivial, oder?
Ich habe keinen Weg gefunden, diesen iCalendar-Server zum Laufen zu bekommen bisher. Naja, er sagt mir, dass er ihn nicht startet, weil, was war noch gleich die Fehlermeldung? Oh Gott, muss ich nochmal hier mal kurz an die Applikation starten. Er hat auf jeden Fall irgendwas zu meckern gehabt, genau, weil irgendwie kein Virtual Host dafür verfügbar sei. Und dann habe ich so das Internet befragt, was das, genau hier, no Virtual Host found for iCal-Service.
Welchen Port läuft der denn? Vielleicht ist der von einer normalen Adresse schon...
More information about the dralala und dralala can be found in the help menu. Wenn du da aber nach iCalender suchst, dann findest du einfach mal gar nichts.
Ist das vielleicht der Name, den du beim Einrichten von 10.5 eingegeben hast? Da muss man nämlich einmal die Domain angeben.
Ich kann mich da nicht dran erinnern, also ich habe da eine Domain angegeben, aber erstens konnte ich die ändern und zweitens ist das jetzt nicht im einigen Sinne das Problem. Ich habe dann das Internet befragt und das Internet hat gesagt, ja, da musst du vorher in der zweiten Applikation, das ist ja so bei Mac OS 10 Server, gibt es zwei Applikationen, die du benutzen musst, um das Ding zu administrieren. Was ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig verstehe. Es gibt Server-Admin und es gibt den Workgroup-Manager. Der Workgroup-Manager kümmert sich halt um User, Gruppen und Computer. Und da rollen mit dann halt auch diese ganzen Preference-Settings. Das ist eigentlich ganz nett. Ich verstehe bloß nicht, warum das dann nochmal ausgelagert wird, weil das hängt eigentlich eh die ganze Zeit alles zusammen.
War das nicht so? War das nicht so? Es gibt diesen Server-Admin, der ist ein bisschen komplexer, und es gibt diesen Workgroup-Manager, der macht das Ganze ein bisschen einfacher.
Nein, nein, im Wesentlichen funktionieren sie ziemlich ähnlich. Und ich sehe nicht so sehr viele Gründe, warum man das nicht so...
Sicher? Also es gibt...
Ist auch egal. Ist auch egal. Es ist so, ich nehme das jetzt erst mal zur Kenntnis, und ich wäre ja auch glücklich, wenn es dann funktioniert. Ich habe dann das Internet befragt, und das Internet hat gesagt, du musst einen Computer anlegen.
Einen Computer?
Ja, du kannst Benutzergruppen und Computer anlegen. Computer sind, dass er weiß, dass es diesen Rechner gibt, so für Netboot und diesen ganzen Kram. Willst du halt auch Computer in der Datenbank haben, dann trägst du dann die MAC-Adressen ein, dass die irgendwie sich identifizieren können, wie die heißen und was die für Preferences haben und so weiter. Also du kannst ja mehr als nur den Server administrieren, du kannst eben auch Rechner, Kleintrechner im Netz damit administrieren. Das ist ja das, wofür MAC OS 10 Server eigentlich auch optimiert ist, so ein Local Area Network im Griff zu haben, mit Login, Präferenzen und so weiter, wie diese Rechner hochkommen, und dann zentrale User, Datenbank und der ganze Schmu. Funktioniert an sich auch ganz gut, oder zumindest, als ich es letztes Mal an der Uni zum Einsatz gebracht habe, funktioniert das ganz gut, es lief mehr oder weniger problemlos. Nur habe ich einfach noch nicht rausbekommen, wie man diesen iCalendar Service startet. Also es hieß dann im Internet, auf den paar Seiten, die ich dazu gefunden habe, man sollte halt einen Computer-Eintrag machen, der eben so heißt wie der Rechner selber, und dann würde das irgendwie alles gehen. Das ging aber nicht. Wobei ich jetzt hier gerade nachschaue und feststelle, dass dieser Eintrag irgendwie verschwunden ist. Ach, das ist echt alles so haarig, ne? Ja, so viel dazu. Also Mac Mini, dieses Frontrohr erkennt komischerweise die Podcasts nicht, die da drauf sind. Der meint, da wären keine Podcasts. Das finde ich ein bisschen scheiße, weil das eigentlich der Hauptgrund ist, weswegen ich mir das Ding dann sozusagen als Media Center holen wollte, dass ich da irgendwie meine Podcasts zentral drauf angucken kann. Gut, ich kann sie jetzt mir immer noch von meinem Laptop irgendwie anschauen, aber das ist natürlich nicht der Reiz, weil da möchte man so tagesschau.de immer haben, dann kann man sich ja so Tagesschau mal angucken und fertig ist. Also abonniert man, das war so meine Idee, man abonniert so die etwas besseren Fernseh-Podcasts, die es gibt, hier so, wie es macht, A und diesen ganzen Klimpel. Und wenn man dann wirklich mal Musa hat, dann nimmt man einfach die Fernbedienung in die Hand, macht Klick und dann guckt man sich das eben an, als wäre es Fernsehen.
So was Ähnliches, das hab ich damals auch angefangen, ich hab ja zu Hause so ein Setup, bestehend aus einer gehackten Xbox und einem Server, auf dem Debian läuft. Debian.
Da müssen wir noch mal drüber reden. Aber spiel mal vor.
Da suche ich dann auch noch einen schönen Podcast-Client, am besten für die Kommandozeile, wo man für exakt das Gleiche, was du auch vorhast, habe ich damals angefangen. Ist eigentlich ganz cool, aber hab's nie zu Ende geführt.
Wie meinst du das exakt das Gleiche?
Na ich hab dann iTunes genommen und iTunes hat dann, also hab dann irgendwie einen Wine installiert, iTunes drauf gepappt, damit ich einen schönen Client habe. Aber iTunes stellt dann nach drei, vier Wochen das Abholen der neuesten Podcast-Version ein, weil man die über iTunes wieder abspielen muss, damit er nicht glaubt, dass man gar keine geguckt hätte. Und wenn man dann auf der Xbox diese Dateien anguckt, dann kriegt iTunes nicht mit, dass man sich den Podcast schon angeguckt hat und stellt irgendwann die Lieferung ein. Dann muss man da immer wieder dämlich rumklickern und hat dann nicht die nächste Folge drauf.
Du hast halt das Evil Empire verlassen.
Hallo?
Ja, ja, ja. Deine These wieder, ne? Du findest Apple ja evil, ne?
Ja, aber man muss auch mal ein bisschen rumlässern. Ich meine, wir machen ja eine Prosendung, da muss auch ein bisschen Contra drin sein.
Was machen wir, eine Prosendung? Meinst du für Profis oder für Pro-Mackintosh?
Pro-Mackintosh.
Ich finde, wir reden hier über Mackintosh und wenn es was Gutes zu berichten gibt, dann stellen wir das irgendwie in gleißenden Farben da und wenn es Negatives gibt, dann wiegeln wir ab.
Genau, wir sind da komplett unvoreingenommen.
So war das gar nicht. Jetzt hab ich diesen blöden Rechner-Eintrag nochmal gemacht und immer noch das gleiche. No Virtual Host found for iCal Service. Also wenn mir jemand von euch erklären kann, wie ich iCalendar Server auf Mac OS 10.5 zum Laufen kriege.
Das hat was mit dem Domain-Namen zu tun, den er eingegeben hat. Es klingt ein bisschen so, als ob ein Apache im Hintergrund laufen würde, der einen Virtual Host braucht. Und den hat er nicht gefunden, weil er den nicht korrekt angelegt hat. Weil er beim hochfahren seinen Domain-Namen nicht auflösen konnte.
Welchen Port braucht ein iCal-Calendar?
8080 oder so was.
8080, so wenn der vom Apache auch schon belegt ist, dann brauchst du natürlich einen anderen Virtual Host.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, 8008.
8008?
Der ist auch nicht belegt. Das ist alles nicht das Problem. Der läuft auch gar nicht, der Webserver. Der muss auch gar nicht laufen dafür. Weil das hier wird separat hoch und runter gefahren. Die einzige Besonderheit ist, dass jetzt mein Rechner ist hinter einem NAT. Ich hab ihm hier irgendwie mit dem Bruder eine feste IP-Adresse gegeben, aber die halt eine lokale ist, 172er irgendwas. Und hab mir ein dünn DNS-Record für die Maschine gemacht, sodass ich eben einen richtigen FQO-DN da eintragen kann, Fully Qualified Domain Name, der halt im Internet gültig ist. Und wenn man eben das auflöst, kommt man dann über das Port Forwarding, was ich auf meiner Time Capsule habe, schon auf den Rechner.
Auch von außen?
Von außen. Zumindest so mit SSH und diesen ganzen Diensten, die ich eingerichtet habe. Und ich hab auch die i-Kalender eingerichtet, auch für mit und ohne SSL. Und naja, wobei mir übrigens noch eine Schwäche der Time Capsule slash Airport extrem bewusst geworden ist, wenn man da nämlich einen Fallserver drauflaufen hat, was ja bei einer Time Capsule sozusagen das ist, weswegen man sich das Ding kauft, dann klemmt das Teil einfach diesen AFP-Defaultport 548 und jetzt kann ich kein Port-Forwarding von außen für AFP auf meinen Server einrichten. Was ist denn das bitte für ein Scheißer? Ja, nimmst du halt einen anderen Port, aber wenn ich halt den Default-Port... Extern meinst du einen anderen Port. Ja, das müsste ich dann halt tun, aber dann muss ich von außen halt immer irgendwie noch mal anderen Port angeben. Naja, macht doch nix.
Das nervt.
Nerv muss jeder User, der dann darauf zugreifen soll, muss das dann halt machen.
Aber da hast du gleich ein bisschen Sicherheit wieder mit dabei.
Tolle Sicherheit.
Super. Warum nimmst du den OS-10-Server nicht als Router? Hat der Mac Mini eigentlich nur einen Ethernet-Port oder zwei?
Na ja, solange das irgendwie die ersten fünf Klicks, die ich hier mache, alle mir irgendwelche obskuren Fehlermeldungen vorwerfen, werde ich das Ding bestimmt nicht als Router betreiben.
Aber das wär's eigentlich, oder? Der machte den Internet, der machte den NAT, der hat dann das Service gleich in alle möglichen Richtungen, dann kriegst du auch eine ordentliche Adresse, die er selber hat.
Kann man drüber nachdenken, aber eigentlich, ja, weiß ich nicht, finde ich das nicht so nötig. Also hätte ich so eine Maschine, die so viele Services offen hat, möchte ich eigentlich auch dann erstmal definieren.
Ich wollte gerade mit dir wetten, dass es mit diesem Fully Qualified Domain Namen zu tun hat, dass der nämlich im internen Netzwerk wahrscheinlich nicht korrekt aufgelöst wird.
Wird er? Ja, klar wird er korrekt aufgelöst. Ich geh dann halt über den Router, ich geh halt sozusagen raus und wieder rein. Beziehungsweise in der Time Capsule wird es dann halt umgeleitet, weil es ja seine IP-Adresse ist. Also das funktioniert. Ich kann von innen SSH, Fully Domain machen.
Ist das so noch volle Geschwindigkeit oder so?
Ich probier's noch mal aus, aber ich dachte, ich hätte es schon ausprobiert. Blablabla, funktioniert, kann ich mich einloggen.
Und welche IP löst der dann auf?
Auf die IP-Adresse von meiner aktuellen dynamischen...
Also von der draußen, von der externen. Das heißt, wenn jetzt der Mac Mini auf die Idee kommt, die beiden IPs...
Wie heißt denn dein Teil?
Welches Teil?
Dein Server?
Das werd ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Wobei, das ist ja wieder Security bei Obscurity. Du musst doch sagen können, ist doch kein Problem, hallo?
Ich kann es dir ja mal aufschreiben und der Rest muss raten. Tut mir leid, Leute, aber irgendwo ist Schluss, ne? So, probierste mal.
Wo steht da MMMM?
Aber diesen Provider gibt es da kostenlose DynDNS-Adressen?
Das ist dyndns.org. Die haben eine ganze Batterie von Top-Level-Domains, wo du auswählen kannst, weil du willst natürlich deinen Lieblings-Rostnamen haben und dann haben sie irgendwie so 20 zur Auswahl mittlerweile. Den finde ich ganz schön. Der ist zwar kryptisch, aber der ist kurz.
Hat deine Kiste auch IPv6?
Ich habe hier IPv6-Connectivity. Was willst du jetzt wissen? Du willst jetzt die IPv6-Adresse von dem Server wissen? Die kann ich dir mal pasten, wenn du mal ins iChat gehst. Das ist hier übrigens der interaktive Mobile-Max-Podcast. Jetzt sitzen wir nicht einfach nur da und reden doof, sondern wir chatten, klicken im Internet, probieren Gadgets aus und reden doof.
Und gucken Filme.
Und das alles gleichzeitig?
Wir werden bestimmt maßlos überziehen. Ich hab dich übrigens noch nicht in meinem Chat, oder?
Ich bin online.
Du bist online?
Ich seh dich auch nicht, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Doch, da oben bist du doch.
Wo bist du denn? Hier bist du. Okay, und jetzt möchtest du gerne eine IPv6-Adresse haben. Wow, das ist meine erste IPv6-Adresse, die ich copy und paste.
Das ist ja nur die Lokale.
Wie ist in deiner Meinung nach der Zustand von IPv6 auf dem Mac?
Eigentlich relativ gut.
Schon länger eigentlich relativ gut, oder? Ist nicht erst seit Leopard richtig gut.
Nee, nee, schon viel länger.
Seit 10.3? Echt? Sodass das einfach so funktioniert?
Vielleicht sogar schon 10.1, ich bin mir nicht so sicher. Ich habe damals viel mit IPsec rumgespielt und das kamen beides gleichzeitig in OS X.
Stimmt, du hast ja auch diese IPsec-Experiment gemacht, aber da musstest du ja immer noch irgendwas austauschen, ne?
Na ganz früher musste ich irgendwie Colonel selber bauen, glaube ich. Und dann haben sie es irgendwie, glaube ich, mit 10.2, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, integriert.
Wie heißt denn nochmal dieses IPsec? Genau, da war doch irgendwie die Version, die bei Mac OS X dabei war.
Früher warst du irgendwie nicht dabei, da musste man selber, und inzwischen ist es dabei. Aber es ist immer noch die alte Version, weil es gibt inzwischen eine neue Raccoon 2, nämlich, und die habe ich jetzt in letzter Zeit, bastel ich damit auch ein bisschen rum und benutze es auch auf Mac und es funktioniert. Es ist ein bisschen schneller im Aufbau von Tunneln und so weiter und so fort.
Okay, also IPsec ist aber jetzt sozusagen das eine, das ist halt verschlüsseltes IP, das geht auch über IPv4. Und du hast, glaube ich, im Club so ein Setup gemacht, dass man irgendwie automatisch verschlüsselt ist.
Ja, da hab ich es gerade nicht so, sondern ich hab für eine Firma halt so ein bisschen, dass die zum Provider eine verschlüsselte Verbindung haben.
Okay, aber IPv6 funktioniert dann auch und funktioniert auch immer noch gut. Das funktioniert übrigens so gut, dass es einem manchmal sogar Ärger macht und man weiß es gar nicht. Ich hatte da neulich einen lustigen Fall, dass ich so einen Podcast bezogen habe.
Das habe ich den gleichen Fehler auch gerade gemacht. Sorry, falls ich kurz unterbrechen darf. Ping6 heißt der Befehl, nicht Ping, sondern Ping6.
Genau, das hätte ich jetzt auch noch sofort rausgefunden. Das Problem ist aber, dass die Adresse, die Tim jetzt gepastet hat, fängt mit fe80 an.
Achso, ich hab die falsche genommen.
Bei IPv6, muss man nicht dazu sagen, kriegt jeder eine lokale Adresse. Genau, hier kommt jetzt eine richtige. Die fängt auch mit 2002 an, das kann man sagen, weil es gibt über IPv6 so viele Adressen, dass es legal ist. Aber im 2002er Bereich, für so einen Experten wie Nibbler zum Beispiel, der weiß dann gleich, wo die herkommt.
Schöner IPv6 ist, dass man einfach dieses Natt-Desaster nicht mehr hat.
Genau.
Man kriegt einfach richtige Adressen, wenn man IPv6-Connectivity hat. Und die hat man heutzutage eigentlich bei keinem Provider. Aber wenn man so eine Time Capsule slash Airport Extreme hat, dann baut das Teil automatischen IPv6-Tunnel über IPv4 auf. Ach ja, das macht er einfach so out of the box.
Hat man es dir schon mal in der Sendung oder hat es das mal woanders erzählt? Im Club hat es dir mal groß berichtet.
Ich habe da mal von berichtet, ich glaube hier hatten wir das noch nicht, also das war auch eine schöne Feststellung, die ich gemacht habe. Und ich kann halt einfach IPv6 hosten. Es gibt ja nicht so viele, aber wenn es welche gibt, kann ich die halt ankicken. Es gibt ja hier dieses...
Und worüber läuft das dann?
Über IPv6.
Nee, aber ich meine, da muss doch irgendwelche Routing-Tabellen geben, das muss doch irgendwo langlaufen. Also ich meine, der Tunnel muss doch irgendwo...
Der Tunnel landet irgendwo, die IPv6 sprechen können.
Das wär doch mal eine spannende Frage.
Dann landet es in dem Internet, wo es eben IPv6 gibt.
Ja, aber gerade mit IPv6 gibt es doch noch... Welche Google-Domain ist das, die IPv6-talklich ist?
Die hatten auch so was, stimmt. Es gibt halt die tanzende Schildkröte von Kame. Das heißt, wenn man die kame.net oder www.kame.net aufruft und zwar mit IPv6, dann schwimmt die Schildkröte. Die macht so schwimmende Bewegungen. Und wenn man sie nur mit IPv4 aufruft, dann ist sie statisch. Und Google hat das nachgemacht. Das heißt, wenn man die Google-Seite mit IPv6 aufruft, dann tanzen die Google-Buchstaben so hoch und runter wie bei so einem Fußballstahl. Ich kenne mich da nicht so aus. Was?
So eine Welle?
Genau, dann gehen die Buchstaben so einzeln hoch nacheinander.
Warte mal, also ich hab hier gerade mal...
Das normale www.google.de.
Nee, die haben da so eine Google-Testseite. Ich weiß nicht, wie die genau heißt.
ipv6.google.com Die habe ich jetzt mal mit Host aufgelöst.
ipv6.google.com Ja, hier, bei mir tanzt die.
Ja genau, sag ich da, la olawelle, genau. Bei dir tanzt gar nichts. Ach, nur einmal, beim ersten Mal.
Ich mach noch mal W-Lords. Zeig mal, guck mal, huu.
Genau, das heißt, du hast die Seite jetzt mit ipv6 aufgerufen.
Aber KameNet ist down irgendwie.
W-W-W, na ich probier das auch mal. www.kame.net Also so Ping klappt auch. War's Org eventuell? Nee, war schon nett, ne?
Voll sportlich die Sendung heute, finde ich.
Nee, KameOrg ist es nicht. Da gelandet man bei so einem Spam-Shit. Nee, aber was ich gerade machen wollte, ist nachdem der Tim meinte, dass er ja ipv6 an seinem Rechner hat und ich mir die Quatsch, die ipv6-Adresse geben lassen. Die meisten Leute haben nämlich ihre Feierwolle nicht auf ipv6 irgendwie eingestellt. Und dann dachte ich, dass ich von meinem Rechner zuhause, der auch ipv6 hat, direkt zu ihm durchpingen kann. Aber geht doch nicht. Weil dann hättest du nämlich alle Ports offen für jeden, der ipv6 hat.
Wär's jetzt bei meinem Server?
Musst du ein bisschen die Augen auf...
Wenn ich was gemacht hätte, hätt ich alle Ports offen?
Na, ich weiß nicht, wie deine Time Capsule das genau macht. Vielleicht filtert sie auch, oder ich weiß nicht, Firewall-mäßig macht sie das ipv6 zu.
Hier bei Airport-Extreme-Time-Capsule gibt's auch eine IPv6-Firewall. Und die ist irgendwie einfach an, bei Default. Man kann hier sagen, Allow Terredo Tunnels. Keine Ahnung, was das ist. Weißt du, was das ist?
Nee, hab ich auch noch nichts von gehört.
Und Allow Incoming IPv6 Authentication.
Du kannst ja mal meine IP...
Und if you want to provide access to specific devices on your network... Blablablabla... Also ich könnte jetzt hier die Adresse eingeben und dann wäre das machbar.
Könnt ihr vielleicht auch noch mitreden? Dann reden wir wirklich alle durcheinander.
Was denn?
Wir müssen die Zuhörer irgendwie... Erzählt weiter.
Wolltest du mich gerade unterbrechen? Also ich versuche gerade nur zu beschreiben, was Airport Extreme macht. Also man kann ja IPv6 Firewall Setup Assistant machen und ich könnte jetzt die IPv6 Adresse von dem Rechner eingeben und dann Allow All Services in Ports oder Specific TCP in UDP Ports und könnte dann TCP UDP Ports angeben. Mit anderen Worten, IPv6 ist by default geblockt. Ich kann dann einzelne Rechner freischalten, kann dann sagen, entweder alles oder eben einzelne Ports. Im Prinzip jetzt nicht anders als bei einer normalen NAT Port Forwarding Geschichte, bloß andersrum. Das heißt, der macht irgendwie erst mal zu und dann musst du explizit wieder aufsagen.
Du kannst jetzt mal die Adresse, die ich dir gepostet hab, kannst du ja mal pingen. Wahrscheinlich ist mein Rechner nämlich offen.
Wieso?
Na, weil ich wahrscheinlich da das nicht IPv6 speziell filter, ich weiß es aber gar nicht.
Also ich kann nicht anpingen. Ist das das, was du meinst? Und meinen anderen kann man nicht anpingen?
Nee, deiner ist halt gefiltert und meiner nicht. Deswegen kannst du jetzt wahrscheinlich über die V6-Adresse direkt...
Wieso ist denn deiner nicht gefiltert?
Na, weil meine Rechner sind alle sicher.
Na, anpingen kann ich meinen auch über eine 2002er-Adresse. Nee, ich nicht.
Ja, lokal, aber nicht von extern.
Ach so, extern kann ich es jetzt gerade nicht testen.
Aber du kannst ja die Adresse, die du von meinem Rechner jetzt hast, anpingen. Das geht?
Ähm, hier lokal dann, ja.
Nur nicht von dem Rechner von meinem zu Hause meine ich.
Die du mir geschickt hast, ist eine... Ja, die kann ich anpingen, ja.
Ja, der ist halt dann offener. Könntest du wahrscheinlich auch SSH auf die Adresse machen.
Das war jetzt der falsche.
Also ich meine, so eine IPv6-Adresse, die besteht ja aus zwei Hälften. Die hintere, die eine von den beiden Hälften, ist im Wesentlichen die MAC-Adresse?
Nö, nicht unbedingt. Das gibt so einen Trick, damit man halt in so einem lokalen Netz, wenn man so einen Range hat, dass man einfach den, der mittlere Teil ist dann die MAC-Adresse, damit jeder Rechner automatisch gleich eine Adresse hat. Aber das muss man auch irgendwie nicht so machen. Aber da gibt es extra so einen Bereich für Reservierten. Ja, es ist auch eine Möglichkeit.
Also eine IPv6-Adresse ist halt viel länger, ist halt 128 Bit, deswegen hast du auch gleich eine hexadezimale Notation, weil die alte Dezimalnotation von IPv4 würde dort keinen Sinn machen. Und du kannst dann bestimmte Bereiche, die nur Nullen sind, kannst du einfach, musst du nicht notieren, sondern dann zwei Doppelpunkte am Anfang oder am Ende, damit kannst du sozusagen solche kompletten Bereiche überspringen. Das heißt, du musst auch nicht immer die vollen 128 Bit schreiben.
Genau, Local Host ist immer fe irgendwas und dann hinten Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt und dann, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Das weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht. Was ist ein Local Host, Dennis? Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall gibt es, Autokonfiguration ist sozusagen Bestandteil von IPv6. Also das, was man sich bei IPv4 alles Mühe, Mühe sammeln hätte machen müssen.
Bei IPv6 ist Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt eins.
Und die...
Loopback Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt null.
Die Sache mit der Autokonfiguration läuft halt einfach so. Er nimmt einfach die MAC-Adresse von dem Ethernet, die 48-Bit und klatscht halt den entsprechenden Prifix davor.
Und dahinter, wo ist denn in der Mitte die MAC-Adresse bei IPv6?
Ja, okay, also er baut auf jeden Fall mit der MAC-Adresse seine Unique-Number zusammen. Einfach davon ausgehen, dass die MAC-Adresse selber unik ist. Wir wissen alle, man kann das bei den Geräten auch ändern, aber die MAC-Adresse ist ja so bei Design, so, dass sie vergeben wird. Und entsprechend bettet er sie eben in so eine Maske mit ein und dann hat er eben einfach schon mal eine Adresse, die im lokalen Netz gültig ist. Das ist keine global routbare Adresse, das ist sozusagen vergleichbar mit einer lokalen Adresse, die ich jetzt von so einem Nattrouter bekomme, mit DACP, so eine 10er-Adresse oder 192, 168. Plus, hier muss überhaupt gar kein DACP gemacht werden, sondern bei IPv6 kann der Rechner einfach sehen, ah, da ist ein Link, dann nehme ich die MAC-Adresse, pack das irgendwie, fremde ich das ein, und dann hab ich eine Adresse.
Ich glaube, ein hübsches Detail des Ganzen war noch, dass man einfach die vordere Hälfte der Adresse, dass man die nämlich austauschen kann. Also unsere externen IPv6-Adressen, die wir jetzt jeweils hier haben, müssten, glaube ich, mit der, die vordere Hälfte müsste übereinstimmen mit der vom Router, und darum sind wir von außen ansprechbar.
Aber ist ja bei IPv4 auch so.
Über IPv4 hat man ja intern komplett andere Adressen als extern.
Ja, wenn du bei IPv4 einen Adressbereich hast, sagen wir mal ein, was früher mal 10 hieß, damit es sich heute nicht aufregt. Da hast du ja vorne auch irgendwie 212, 202, 251, Punkt 1. Und deine anderen Rechner haben Punkt 2, Punkt 3, Punkt 4. Und vorne, die drei Stellen bleiben gleich. Was ist jetzt da dann das Speziale?
Also Network Host, das Prinzip ist Beibehalt. Das heißt jetzt einfach alles andere. Du hast halt irgendwie da so deinen Prefix. So, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist es so...
Nee, nee, nee, nee, da gibt es noch einige hübsche Details. Zum Beispiel gibt es so dieses, dass man einen Rechner... Also ich könnte meinen Rechner jetzt rausnehmen. Dein Router würde mitbekommen. Alles klar, der Max ist jetzt gar nicht mehr hier in unserem lokalen Netzwerk drinnen. Weil sich mein Rechner angemeldet hat von außen.
Achso, du meinst so Roaming?
Genau, solches.
Du meinst diese Mobile-Features irgendwie, dass man irgendwie...
Also ich hab die jetzt... Sollten wir vielleicht wirklich mal eine eigene Sendung drüber machen.
Ja, das kommt jetzt zu weit. Das ist auch mal was, was ich schon für Chaos Radio Express mir vornotiert habe, aber bisher...
Aber es ist schön, dass du was mit der...
Tatsache ist... Der Mac......extreme geht... .hat brauchbare IPv6 verfordert. Und jetzt erzähl ich nochmal meine Geschichte, die ich vorhin schon erzählen wollte, mit den entsprechenden Pitfalls. Ich hatte nämlich einen Podcast abonniert. Und für eine gewisse Zeit, oder seit irgendwann... Hört mir jemand zu?
Alle.
Du hast einen Podcast abonniert. Für eine gewisse Zeit, bis du vor sechs eingestellt hast, ging der.
Nein, irgendwann bekam ich keine Updates mehr von diesem Podcast. Mal iTunes sagte er einfach, Host nicht da. Ich hab die Webseite angeklickt und Safari meint, irgendwie Webseite gibt's nicht, irgendwie not found, alles scheiße, deine Elsa. Dann bin ich irgendwie in den Chat gegangen und wusste ja, von wem dieser Podcast ist und hab den Jungs Bescheid gesagt, hier euer Server ist down. Und die meinten irgendwie so, nö, läuft alles prima, ist kein Problem, was hast du denn? Und dann bin ich wahnsinnig geworden. Ich hab irgendwie auf meinem Rechner rumgeklickt und das Ding war irgendwie nicht zu machen. Bin ins Terminal gegangen, hab das Ding angepinkt und was war? Der Rechner war halt da. Also es ging, da hab ich Links und Links gestartet auf der Kommandozeile. Alles da. Der Podcast war da, die MP3-Falls, die URLs waren da, alles war da, der Webserver lief, ich wieder meinen Safari in meinen iTunes-Nix ging, bis ich irgendwann so drauf kam. Es ging auf der Kommandozeile immer, weil dort alles IPv4 ist bei Default. Aber wenn der Rechner IPv6 hat, dann macht das Ganze GUI. Alles was bei OS X sozusagen mit dem Application Frameworks arbeitet, alle richtigen Mac OS X Anwendungen machen dann bei Default zuerst IPv6, wenn der Rechner eine IPv6 Adresse hat. Und das war das Problem. Sie hatten nämlich ein AAA-Rekord eingetragen, also eine IPv6 Adresse im DNS für diesen Rechner. Aber über die IPv6 Adresse lief der Web-Server nicht. Also ihr Web-Server war über IPv6 nicht erreichbar, auch wenn er gesagt hat, dass es eine IPv6 Adresse gibt.
Das war schlicht und ergreifend eine Fehlkonfiguration.
Es war eine Fehlkonfiguration, aber ich brauchte wirklich Tage und Wochen, bis ich dieses Problem überhaupt mehr so isoliert habe. Dann konnte ich ihnen halt sagen, hier, das ist euer Problem. Dann war es natürlich auch sofort gefixt. Aber das ist sozusagen etwas, also wenn jemand von euch diesen Effekt hat, dass er partout mit einer GUI-Applikation einen Service nicht erreicht, der aber auf der Kommandozeile offensichtlich da zu sein scheint, dann kann es daran liegen, dass hier so eine IPv6-Konfusion vorliegt, dass einer den Rechner mit zwei Adressen im Netz hat, aber die Services halt nicht laufen.
Curl6 und Weget6 und so weiter und so fort gibt es denn auch? Und Lynx6?
Viele Tools haben, also entweder eine Option minus 4 oder minus 6 als Option. Genau, gibt es ganz häufig so minus 6, minus 4. Beziehungsweise diesen selber IPv6-Aware und gucken halt selber erst mal nach dem IPv6-Rekord. Wenn es den gibt, benutzen sie den, wenn du halt nicht direkt eine Adresse angibst.
Wenn man hier im Finder so diesen Bonjour-gelisteten Rechner irgendwie anklickt, weil man zum Beispiel auch File Sharing machen will, also Apple File Sharing, dann benutzt der per Default auch IPv6, wenn es zur Verfügung steht. Und SSH genau das gleiche. Man kann ja im Terminal auch sich die Rechner anzeigen lassen, die einen SSH-Port annoucen. Muss man übrigens auffassen, man annouzt immer seinen SSH-Port. Und das geht dann auch mit IPv6, wenn man es denn hat.
Na gut, so könnte ich meine Services zumindest über IPv6 bereitstellen. Müssen wir mal gucken, ob DynDNS eigentlich auch schon IPv6 unterstützt. Das weiß ich gar nicht.
Aber auf jeden Fall, dass da alles so schön durchgerutet wird, das ist ja immer eine schöne Sache. Das scheint irgendwo in Amsterdam zu werden, wenn ich das hier richtig sehe.
Alles wird besser mit IPv6.
Also da scheint Apple ja doch mal sehr schön hinterher zu sein, im Gegensatz zu anderen Firmen.
Wie hinterher?
Na gut, aber auch.
Also hinterher von hinterher oder von hinterher?
Hinterher im Sinne von weit vorne, wir machen das, wir forcieren es.
Es ist bei Windows, wisst ihr nicht anders.
Genau, aber auch bei XP, glaube ich. Die haben alle schon ziemlich viel Support. Eigentlich ist es nicht das Problem von den OS-Herstellern, sondern es ist eher, ich glaube die Router-Hersteller haben auch alle schon IPv6 irgendwie im Produkt.
Ist eine Provider-Geschichte.
Ist eher eine Provider-Geschichte, dass die noch keinen Bock haben umzustellen, weil das sind scheiße Lanktieradressen. Wenn man die alle tippen muss, dann macht das keinen Spaß.
Das Problem ist natürlich vielfältig. Erstmal gibt es eine ganze Menge Probleme, die so ähnlich sind wie das, was ich gerade erzählt habe. Auf einmal machen alle by default IPv6 und dann sind auf einmal irgendwelche Dienste nicht zu erreichen.
Das eigentliche Problem ist, dass es einen Übergang geben muss. Weil wenn sie einfach umschalten können, wäre alles total schick, aber es muss eine Weile beides gehen. Und dann kommen deine Übergangsprobleme.
Gib mal her das Kabel hier. Strom für Max.
Brot für die Welt, Strom für Max.
Jetzt müssen wir aber das Thema bringen auf IPv6 von irgendjemanden.
Ich glaube mehr als genug.
Ich hätte es gerne, dass der Provider das langsam anbieten, weil dann würde es auch mal richtig losgehen. Weil die großen, die die Adressen vergeben international, die IPv4-Adressen noch drei Jahre halten und dann ist vorbei.
Dann wird hier schon mit den großen...
Drei Jahre? Ist das jetzt eine verlässliche Aussage? Ich meine, dass es irgendwann mal knapp wird. Ist so ein bisschen wie mit dem Öl, ne?
Ist wie mit dem Öl. Sie sagen es ja schon seit ziemlich langer Zeit, dass es bald knapp ist. Aber jetzt sagen sie drei Jahre, es kann natürlich immer noch sein, sie rufen halt große Firmen auf, unbenutzte Adressbereiche zurückzugeben. Und Apple zum Beispiel, weil sie schon so lange mit dabei sind, die haben von IPv4 alles, was mit 17 anfängt gehört. Apple, das sind 16 Millionen Adressen. Apple braucht keine 16 Millionen Adressen. Und die könnten zum Beispiel einen Blog zurückgeben, aber ist natürlich schwierig, wenn die schon irgendwie in ihrem Bereich vorne, hinten, links und überall in der Mitte so ein paar Bereiche gegriffen haben, dann kann man ja nicht die Hälfte davon abgeben und man kann nicht kleine Bereiche, dann ist es wieder mit dem Routing schwierig, deswegen will man ja von IPv4 weg. Also es geht nicht so richtig mit dem Adressen zurückgeben.
Naja, das können sie schon machen. Also kann mir keiner erzählen, dass sie nicht zumindest ein paar Millionen irgendwie frei arbeiten.
Sie müssten eine ganze Hälfte frei geben und wenn sie in beiden Hälften die benutzt haben, dann ist es halt schwierig, von dem 17 irgendwie die eine Hälfte frei zu geben.
Was heißt schwierig? Ich meine, es ist eine Routing-Konfiguration.
Das sind vielleicht ganze Land-Apple-Liederlassungen, die komplett deploitert und dann kannst du den nicht mal so einfach die Adressen wegnehmen.
Wenn ich der Admin wäre, würde ich da erstmal schön eine Runde durchdrehen.
Die wartet wahrscheinlich noch, bis die richtig viel wert sind.
Wenn ich Steve wäre, würde ich es auch gar nicht weggeben, weil es halt wir haben die 17 und sonst niemand.
Und vor allem, wer außer uns sollte wissen, wie man das wirklich zur Anwendung bringt. Oder?
Außerdem wollen sie ja wahrscheinlich auch IPv6 pushen.
Wir zeigen euch einfach, was man mit IPv4-Adressen machen kann, worauf noch nie einer gekommen ist.
Rückwärtschreiben.
Nee, irgendwie, was weiß ich, Capri rollen. Vielleicht machen sie ja dann doch nochmal irgendwie ihr eigenes Netzwerk auf für... Auf IPv4-Basis?
Mit 16 Millionen Adressen?
Na, IPv4 ist here to stay. Also ich meine, wie viele Web-Server laufen heute unter IPv6? Fast keiner.
Ja, aber das muss irgendwann...
Das muss irgendwann, aber das ist... In 10 Jahren ist das noch nicht geschehen.
Also das...
Gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal, aber das ist mal meine These.
Was, was, was? Ich wollte es vorhin schon... Ich hab es vorhin schon mal unauffällig angesprochen. Was ist eigentlich aus unserer lustigen kleinen Wette geworden?
Ich hab noch ein paar Tage. Wenn jetzt in den nächsten 5 Tagen noch beratzt gegeben wird... Also iPhone, genau. Wir haben gewettet, dass ich der Meinung war, dass bis zum Mai irgendeine Art Release, Pressrelease, was auch immer rauskommt, dass irgendjemand sagt, das iPhone wäre das meistverkaufte Smartphone in Deutschland. Richtig?
So in etwa. Außer, dass du aufgeschrieben hast, dass es um das meistverkaufte Telefon sogar geht.
Ach, die Werte schon wieder. Das hatten wir doch schon mal.
Jaja, aber jetzt ist es soweit. Ich hab nicht mal das Smartphone gesagt. Das war äußerst unklug von mir, weil da hätte ich ja jetzt noch einen Strohhalm gehabt.
Definitiv, aber...
Na okay, also die Kiste Mate kann ich sozusagen schon mal kaufen. Trotz alledem gab es ja eine Verlautbarung dazu. Telekom hat gesagt, sie hätten 100.000 verkauft.
Was eine ziemlich okaye Zahl ist eigentlich, oder?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher. Ist das eine okaye Zahl?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Was ist denn 100.000 Telefone in Deutschland verkaufen? In fünf Monaten.
Na wahrscheinlich ist das schon jetzt voll viel, weil Nokia hat halt irgendwie 30 verschiedene Telefone im Angebot. Und die haben natürlich einzeln nicht mehr als 100.000 verkauft. Glaube ich. Weil sie halt 20, 30 verschiedene haben.
Das Ding ist, wir kennen die anderen Zahlen nicht. Und wir kennen auch keine wirklich gut... Also ich kenne zumindest keine Quelle, wo wirklich mal nachzulesen wäre, von welchem Telefon wie viel in Deutschland verkauft wird. Wahrscheinlich diese Zahlen einfach nicht erhoben werden. Zumindest nicht so ohne weiteres.
Steht nicht zu erwarten, dass die Telekom durchaus erwähnt hätte, wenn es das meistverkaufte Smartphone in Deutschland überhaupt ist?
Das würde ich aber nur tun, das war wahrscheinlich mein Fehler. Ich bin davon ausgegangen, dass sowas sich problemlos feststellen lässt. Das lässt sich wahrscheinlich nicht problemlos feststellen. Was ist denn bitte die Konkurrenz? Da gibt es das LG-Phone, dieses Beauty, dann gibt es irgendwie dieses N95. Das ist alles Trash. Ich glaube schon, dass es das meistverkaufte Smartphone ist in Deutschland. Aber wissen tue ich es nicht. Insofern habe ich wahrscheinlich verloren, es sei denn die Hörer können mich irgendwie noch retten. Aber ist ja nun auch vollkommen egal, denn das neue iPhone steht vor der Tür. Ich denke, ich war ja noch sehr skeptisch in den letzten Wochen.
Der Tim ist ja Apple-User und hat ja noch kein iPhone.
Ich werde mir das 3G-iPhone auf jeden Fall kaufen.
Es gibt einen zu denken. Aber weißt du, was ich heute gehört habe beim Tim? Es klingelt sein Telefon und welchen Ton hört man?
Nein, nicht Marimba.
Doch, Marimba ist super. Das ist der erste erträgliche Klingelton, den ich in meinem Leben gehört habe.
Den habe ich als erstes ausgewechselt.
Den fand ich so dermaßen korrekt. Das war mal ein richtiger Ton, einer der nicht auf den Sack geht. Ja, ich habe ja nicht gesagt, dass ich nicht affin bin. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass das 2,5G-iPhone einfach meine Anforderungen nicht erfüllt. Und alles was ich bisher gehört habe von dem 3G-iPhone, also man hat ja eigentlich nichts gehört, weil es gibt ja keine Informationen, aber das was sich so abzeichnet, würde ich sagen, da bin ich dann dabei.
Übrigens, worüber wir letztes Mal noch schön rumdiskutiert haben, über den Sinn und Verstand des 3G-Buttons in der neuen Firmware-Version, ist gefaked gewesen.
Das hatte ich auch gedacht, weil wenn keine anruft, dann ist es auch egal, wenn wir auch noch nichts ausschalten. Und immer sowas, das war sauber geklappt.
Ja, aber jedes UMTS-Telefon hat eine Option, dass man 3G abschalten kann. Also jedenfalls jedes Sony Ericsson, was ich bisher hatte. Echt?
Ach, Nokia auch? Das kann natürlich sein.
Nokia, da musst du einfach auf Einstellungen, den dritten Tab von oben dreimal im Kreis drehen.
Advanced, Profiles, Extras.
Nokia konfigurieren ist ungefähr so wie...
Das geht gar nicht. Ist das dein Klingelton?
Nee, nur wenn eine spezielle Freundin anruft.
Eine spezielle Freundin? Wie viele spezielle Freundinnen gibts? Aha, na dann warten wir mal.
Und wenn, ich bin ja Motorradfahrer, vielleicht machen wir ja auch nochmal eine Sendung, wenn die anrufen, dann kommt...
Wenn Motorradfahrer anrufen? Und wie machst du das Problem, wenn Leute in zwei Gruppen sind? Irgendwie, wenn deine spezielle Freundin jetzt dich ein Motorrad kauft?
Es ist so.
Wollen wir es mal nicht nennen?
Unabhängig von mir auch, mit dem Führerschein angefangen, mit Motorradführerschein. Ist wahr. Und ich weiß nicht, ob sie jetzt schon fertig, sie müsste eigentlich, weil ich hab jetzt schon eine Weile lang nicht mehr gesprochen. Ich hab die Hafer schon lange nicht mehr gehört. Ich hab mich nicht gemeilt, ich bin schuld. Wie es immer so ist. Und ja, dann hab ich ein Problem. Dann müsste die klingende Hafer auf dem Motor, ist egal. Okay, wir schweifen ab.
Wir schweifen ab. Also ich denke mal, wir müssen jetzt, wir müssen der Realität ins Auge blicken. Und ich glaub, die Realität ist, das Scheißteil kommt jetzt tatsächlich. Weil bei so dermaßen vielen Announcements, um die ganze Welt herum, und so viele Telekurs, die das iPhone demnächst führen werden, haben gesagt, also es gibt, glaub ich, mindestens zwei oder drei Versprecher von irgendwelchen Leuten, denen wahrscheinlich mittlerweile schon die Hände oder die Zungen abgehackt wurden, die gesagt haben, wir werden ein 3G-iPhone verkaufen. Ich glaube, in Italien hat sich einer verplappert, in der Schweiz hat sich einer verplappert.
Einer von AT&T.
AT&T will bis Mitte Juni den 3G-Ausbau abgeschlossen haben.
Ja, das Netz.
Wofür denn?
Na ja gut, das ist eine Mutmaßung. Aber die anderen haben halt gesagt, wir werden ein 3G-iPhone haben. Keine Sache, die hasst Steve Jobs wie die Pest. Und das ist, wenn ihm jemand die Show stealt.
Stealed.
Ich würde sagen, das ist eine Sendung der heutigen Sendung im Kopf von Steve Jobs. Wenn ihm einer die Show stealt.
Was im Kopf von Steve Jobs?
Ich stell mir grad so ein bisschen vor.
Das soll der Titel sein oder was?
Ich glaub, das war jetzt...
Das werden wir erst am Ende wissen, das ist geil. Vielleicht kommt ja noch was Unterhaltsames und Lustiges in diesem Podcast.
Du hast Hoffnung.
Ich will doch nur sagen, wenn ich schon glaube, dass es kommt...
Ich blätter mal kurz im Script vor.
Dass es kommt, ist doch mal ganz klar. Es fällt nur die Frage, wann, ob es zur WWDC kommt oder später.
Ich denke, es wird dort einfach announced werden.
Ich denke auch, es wird nur announced werden und es wird dann zwei, drei Wochen später kommen.
Also ich glaube, es wird... also kommen.
Alle Developer nehmen eins mit nach Hause. Und wir müssen jetzt das Bingo irgendwie ankreuzen, weil wir sind in zwei Wochen, werden wir uns hier an diesem Tisch wieder treffen und dann ist, wir werden sogar zwei Tage später aufnehmen. Werden wir? Weil, wenn wir es nämlich in zwei Wochen, heute ist nämlich Montag und wenn wir es machen würden, wäre jetzt gerade Keynote.
Heute in zwei Wochen ist Keynote.
Und wir werden nicht live während der Keynote den Podcast aufnehmen.
Ich werde nicht mehr schlafen können.
Was danach oder davor?
Bis dahin.
Bis dahin. Genau. Und wir treffen uns zwei Tage danach und dann werden wir diesen ganzen Kram anhalten.
Ich glaube, diese Keynote wird nicht so spannend werden.
Und dann werden wir die ganze Zeit auf unseren 3G-Iphones rumspielen.
Das glaube ich ja nicht. Aber die Frage ist, werden alle Developer alles mit nach Hause nehmen können?
Die haben alle mal eine Maus bekommen, als sie rauskamen. Aber ein iPhone, glaube ich nicht. Wusstest du noch, wo die alle unterm Stuhl, haben die Maus unter den Stuhl geklebt und dann meinte er, es darf jetzt mal jeder unter seinen Stuhl greifen. Das habe ich leider nicht gesehen.
Das klingt so ein bisschen Oprah-mäßig.
Ich glaube, war es sogar diese Runde oder war es schon die neuere? Das war die neuere, die ovale. Weil den roten Puck ging ja immer gar nicht.
Was war das, die Wireless-Maus oder was?
Nee, nee, nee, noch mit Chord.
Die schwarze Eintast-Maus, die sind nach dem Hockey-Puck eingeführt worden. Bild ich mir ein.
Nee, nicht schwarz, sondern die war ja glasig, durchsichtig.
Ja, aber innen war die schwarz.
Unten war sie schwarz und da drüber war so.
Und wenn man sie eine Weile in der Hand gehalten hat, dann sah sie immer ganz frisch aus.
Und die hat auch noch nur eine Maustaste. Ich glaube, ich habe die noch zu Hause irgendwie, aber ist horrible.
Ach, die Mäuse beim Apple.
Ich habe ja eine Mighty-Maus. Mit der bin ich sehr, sehr glücklich.
Also da das iPhone, glaube ich, im nächsten Podcast das absolute Megathema sein wird, machen wir heute mal ein bisschen weniger. Genau, machen wir mal ein bisschen weniger iPhone.
Was ich vermute von der WWDC ist, weil das 10.05 ist ja letztes Jahr im Oktober erst rausgekommen. Das nächste Jahr, wenn es wieder zwei Jahre dauert, dann ist 2009, ist ja schon nächstes Jahr.
Meinst du, machen sie ein 10.06-Preview?
Nee, machen sie eben nicht, weil es zu früh ist.
Das glaube ich auch nicht.
Obwohl, beim letzten Mal kam das erste 10.05, wurde auch ganz schön früh vorgestellt und dann dachte man, das kommt ja dann mal irgendwann und dann kam es aber trotzdem erst eineinhalb Jahre später. So gesehen, könnten sie sich schon irgendwas vorstellen?
Was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist, sie haben ja großspurig angekündigt, sowohl OS X für den Mac als auch das OS X iPhone. Also auch eine andere Namensgebung ist da mit drin. Weil vorher hieß es, jetzt komme ich ganz durcheinander, wie hieß es denn vorher? Vorher war immer nur von OS X irgendwie die Rede. OS X 1.0, das war das, was auf dem iPhone läuft. Das war das Betriebssystem.
Jetzt heißt es ja auch 2.0.
Jetzt reden sie mehr von OS X für den Mac und OS X von dem iPhone. Das heißt, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie eine Unification machen. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie auch Coco Touch auf den Mac bringen. Ich meine, die Trackpads sind jetzt schon so multitouch und sie haben Gs.
Wenn sie es dann aber bringen, kommt auch die passende Hardware dafür raus.
Vielleicht haben sie diese Hardware ja schon in Form von Trackpads.
Ich behaupte mal, dass diese Versionsnummerierung, die sie haben, also das ist auf dem iPhone, dass das dann die Softwareversion 2.0 ist, dass das mehr Marketing ist, weil das können sie ja nicht auch 10.5. nennen oder sowas, aber die Kernel-Version wird wahrscheinlich dann auch von 10.5. designen oder sowas.
Das ist derselbe Kernel, das ist klar. Es handelt sich ja ohnehin um Leopard. Die iPhone-Betriebssoftware muss ja jetzt nicht zwingend mit dem OS sozusagen zusammenhängen.
Genau, das sind einfach die mitgelieferten Programme, die da noch mit reinstehen. Und bis es Touch auf den Desktop geben wird, bin ich ehrlich gesagt noch relativ skeptisch.
Außerdem ist ja auf dem Screen Touch, wo man sieht was anderes, als wenn man hier aufs Trackpad irgendwie toucht und nicht weiß, wo man auf dem Screen gerade so richtig ist.
Zumindest für sowas wie Gestenerkennung brauchst du irgendwie einen API. Du willst halt irgendwie so das machen. Warum sollten Sie bitte noch was anderes erfinden, als das, was wir ohnehin auf dem Phone haben?
Das glaube ich nicht, aber ich sehe es ein bisschen. Also wenn man das iPhone ein bisschen in der Hand gehabt hat, dann sieht man doch, dass das schon was sehr, sehr anderes als eine klassische Mac ist. Insofern, dass da die Gelegenheit genutzt wurde, so ein User Interface noch mal komplett neu zu erfinden oder weitgehend neu zu erfinden. Und die Möglichkeit existiert auf dem Mac so ganz klassisch erstmal nicht.
Okay, vielleicht ist es auch alles nur Marketing-Kram. Trotzdem glaube ich, dass sie einfach schon durch diese Namensnennung im Vorfeld werden sie einfach stärker darauf hinweisen, dass Programmieren auf dem iPhone quasi dir die Tür öffnet, zum Programmieren auf dem Mac. Das ist die erste WWDC, die ausverkauft ist.
Und andersrum.
6000 Leute oder so werden das dann wahrscheinlich sein. Oder wie viele sind da? Die allererste, ausverkaufte WWDC. Wir wissen alle, warum das so ist. Das ist einerseits so, weil der Macintosh populärer ist, aber vor allem, weil jede Scheißfirma da jemand hinschickt und sagt, du musst lernen, wie man auf dem iPhone Anwendungen programmieren soll. Die werden einfach mit einer Shitload of Applications rauskommen, wenn dieser Upsell läuft. Und alle wollen das jetzt machen. Und was zieht das groß? Myriaden an Coco-Programmierer.
Objective-Sea, dann wird es endlich mal gepumpt.
Es wird jetzt anbegonnen, Objective-Sea zu programmieren. Das ist eine echte Revolution. Das ist die Gelegenheit für Apple, die Leute gleich mitzunehmen und zu sagen, ach so, übrigens, wenn ihr sowieso schon den ganzen Kram euch fürs iPhone reinzieht, dann braucht ihr nur noch 2, 3 Sachen zusätzlich zu lernen. Und schon seid ihr Macintosh-Programmierer.
Wobei, ich glaube, das wird doch eine ganze Weile dauern. Die sollen erstmal vermutlich alle schön iPod Touch bzw. iPhone-Anwendungen schreiben. Und dann irgendwann später auch noch...
Die sollen beides machen.
Aber das Cocoa ist so schick und fein gemacht, die werden dann ganz schnell rübergezogen. Weil es ist echt bequem.
Das ist ein Development Environment. Warum sollten sie das nicht betonen? Das finde ich schon wichtig.
Sie werden dann Xcode 3.1 final auf der WWDC rausgeben. Er wird dann sagen, so downloadable right now.
Also was ich glaube, ich glaube, wir werden das iPhone wirklich relativ sofort haben, am nächsten Tag oder sowas. Wir haben ja zwei Wochen mehr.
Jetzt kannst du die Wette um den gleichen Betrag und dann könnt ihr euch gegenseitig neu hin.
Das ist doch keine Kiste Mate wert.
Was noch? Ich glaube, ansonsten wird es insofern, wir werden noch einige Features, die wir von der iPhone Software Firmware 2.0 sehen werden wir noch nicht kennen, werden wir da sehen.
Wird das GPS haben? Ja.
Ja, die Software hat, die letzte Beta hat Geo-Tagging mit in den Fotodings drin.
Und du meinst, das machen sie nicht mit ihrem Sky Spyhook Wireless? Warum nicht? Du könntest so deine Location einfach anzeigen, so wie jetzt auch und dann refinest du die und sagst, nee, ich bin aber da. Und dann kannst du es halt auch geotaggen damit.
Würde gehen.
Ich behaupte mal, dass Apple ein ganz simples GPS drin hat, davon habe ich irgendwann mal vor einem halben Jahr oder so was gehört und zwar ist das funktioniert ein bisschen anders, da hat man nur noch ein simpelses Radio drin, im Telefon selbst oder im Gerät, das war für Geotagging von Fotos gedacht. Und nachher, wenn das Foto gemacht, also das nimmt quasi den Schuss auf, was die GPS-Satelliten gerade senden an Daten.
Und rechnet später aus, wo es gewesen ist.
Und rechnet später aus, wo es gewesen ist. Und das wäre eigentlich für Apple genau die Technologie, die sie brauchen. Einfach Internet gestützt, das Ganze zu machen.
Wie soll das dann später ausrechnen?
Es gibt einen Service, du hast überall einfach GPS-Empfänger stehen, weltweit, die genau diese Signale abhören und die dich darüber dann positionieren können später.
Was ist jetzt A-GPS?
Ist das, ne, Assisted GPS ist doch...
Das läuft so ein bisschen, also Assisted GPS basiert genau da drauf. Du empfängst sozusagen deine rohe Position, aber du rechnest nicht selber wirklich aus. Sondern machst es sozusagen gestützt durch das Netzwerk.
Genau, ich dachte, das wäre aber...
Das hat aber irgendwie kein Provider so richtig implementiert.
Dann macht's Apple.
Aber das würde ja auch bedeuten, dass alle Telcos, mit denen Apple jetzt gerade rausgeht...
Ne, ne, ne, ne, das hat gar nichts mit den Telcos zu tun. Überhaupt nicht, das ist das Allergeringste. Dann ist RGPS was anderes als du meinst.
Ich glaube auch, das ist das andere. Die haben ja was erzählt, dass sie nur die Daten einfangen und das irgendwie nicht der Chip ausrechnen, was irgendwie viel Saft kosten würde.
Nicht nur viel Saft, sondern auch viel Zeit.
Rechnet man irgendwie später einfach.
Du nimmst einfach nur auf, wo...
Aber warum könnte das iPhone das dann nicht selber rechnen? Sind die Berechnungen so hardcore, dass nicht irgendwie der 500 Megahertz Prozessor da drin es berechnen könnte?
Die Berechnungen sind überhaupt nicht das Problem. Das Problem ist, dass man muss ja, um die Position einmalig zu ermitteln, musst du von allen Satelliten irgendwie ein Signal oder nicht von allen, aber von ein paar Satelliten einmal die aktuelle Position bekommen haben. Und die senden die nicht im Mikrosekunden-Takt, sondern die senden die nur alle 30 Sekunden. Und wenn du dann nicht auf Anhieb etwas empfängst, dann hast du so eine Fixzeit von einer Minute oder so was. Und wenn du den Sprung einfach übergehst, indem du einfach das aufzeichnest und dann das sozusagen an den zentralen Server sendest, die Daten, die du aufgezeichnet hast, und der sagt dann, wir haben da einen Berlin GPS-Empfänger rumliegen.
Also seit dem Surf3-Chip ist eigentlich so ein Fixkriegen nur noch für Nokia ein Problem. Also die haben das irgendwie nicht implementiert bekommen, im N95, aber jedes billige Bluetooth-Teil hatte heutzutage eigentlich wenig Probleme.
Wie lange dauert so ein Fix mittlerweile?
Im Sekundenbereich ist das.
Ja, klar ist das ein Sekundenbereich. In wieviel Sekundenbereich?
In wenigen Sekundenbereich. Das reicht auf jeden Fall vollkommen aus, wenn du dein Mobiltelefon durch die Gegend trägst, dann weißt das einfach immer, wo du bist. So, dieser Fix ist ja auch nur dann wirklich ein Problem, wenn du eine längere Strecke beim ausgeschaltetem Gerät zurückgelegt hast, weil dann hat es eine verwirrende Konstellation.
Beziehungsweise nicht.
Du siehst nicht genug Satelliten und hast Schwierigkeiten, dann nachzuführen. Es gibt aber auch schon die nächste Generation von GPS-Chips, weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie die heißen, also quasi Nachfolger von dem SIRV3, die das nochmal verbessern. Das ist SIRV4. Das ist halt tatsächlich noch im Zusammenhang mit GSM. Dann kriegst du eben diese Hilfsdaten aus dem Netz, also es berechnet nicht das Netz deine Position, sondern du kriegst sozusagen die vorberechneten Satellitentabellen vom Netz für deinen Bereich, weil du empfängst es ja von einer bestimmten Zelle. Du bist ja in einer Zelle. Die Zelle weiß ja, wo sie ist. Das heißt, die Zelle beobachtet für dich die Satelliten.
Also diese Variante, nee, nee.
Es gibt diese Information an das Telefon und dann braucht das Telefon weniger zu rechnen, weil sozusagen die Zelle für einen mitbeobachtet.
Also sagen wir so, zum einen wäre ja, wenn das dieses RGPS ist, ist es definitiv eine andere Variante. Weil es ist eigentlich gar nicht gedacht für Mobiltelefone, sondern zum Beispiel für Kameras, die gar keinen GSM-Netzanschluss haben. Also insofern sprechen wir jetzt nochmal von zwei unterschiedlichen Parachuten. Aber selbst so etwas wie RGPS könnte natürlich Apple mit Leichtigkeit sagen, T-Mobile, AT&T, hier, wenn ihr, also ihr wollt das neue iPhone haben, bitte packt diese Information zusätzlich noch in euer Netz rein. Das ist ja nun wirklich...
Ja, das heißt aber, dass jede Base Station sozusagen auch den Himmel beobachten muss.
Dann wird sie das tun müssen, genauso wie sie jetzt. Die werden es ja sehen. Beziehungsweise, also wie gesagt, ich glaube, es wird eher die Variante sein, die ohne die Telcos auskommt, sondern...
Also Dennis, du meinst, das Teil hat GPS? Einfach so ein normales GPS mit dem neuesten Stein und der macht das?
Ich glaube nicht, dass es so ein Profi-GPS ist, sondern mehr so die gehen in Richtung Sparsam. Es muss ja auch nicht schnell gehen, so viel Bilder schießen, der kann da ruhig eine Minute mal gucken oder eine halbe.
Ey, das ist einfach... Diese Technik existiert seit Jahren.
Die brauchen doch nichts Tolles zum Ruten oder so.
Du kannst dir für 30... Du kannst dir irgendwie in Asien für 30 Dollar so ein Bluetooth-GPS-Teil mit einem Surf-3-Chip holen. Das macht das einfach in Ordnung.
Aber das ist viel zu teuer, so 30 Dollar.
End-User-Preis, wenn es nach Deutschland schickst, verpackt in so ein Stück Plastik, nicht Apple baut das in Millionen Fonds ein und...
Aber auch Apple muss ja sparsam umgehen, die haben da auch nicht so viel Platz drin und die Batterie hält auch nicht ewig. Also die können das nicht dauerhaft anlassen.
Der Chip ist nicht das Problem. Das einzige Problem, was ich sehe, ist Antenne. Das Telefon muss einen guten GPS-Empfang haben. Das muss die Satelliten zuverlässig auswerten können. Und das wird sich eben zeigen. Nokia hat es beim N95 nicht hinbekommen.
Außerdem, wenn man beim Nokia N95 GPS anhat, braucht das unglaublich viel Strom.
Ja, das UMTS-Problem. Also ich denke mal, diese Sachen lassen sich lösen. Mich würde es jetzt auch nicht überraschen, wenn GPS nicht dabei ist. Weil sie haben jetzt auch gerade Job-Descriptions rausgebracht, wo sie nach GPS-Engineers suchen. Also wenn sie jetzt wirklich schon GPS einbauen und jetzt erst anfangen dafür irgendwie fähige Köpfe zu suchen, da würde ich mich halt auch so ein bisschen am Kopf kratzen. Kann natürlich aber auch sein, dass sie in Zukunft jetzt erstmal einen GPS-Stein benutzen, der irgendwie noch draufpasst, damit sie das Feature schon mal haben und es passt irgendwie in die Kalkulation, aber in Zukunft wollen sie das in ihrer eigenen ASICS, die sie hier mit ihrer neu gekauften Semi-PA-Cro designen wollen, dass sie da GPS mit reinbauen wollen, um einfach einen günstigen Stein zu haben und das iPhone nochmal 100 Dollar billiger zu nehmen.
Ich würde es auch gar nicht schlimm finden, wenn sie das GPS sich per Bluetooth holen von so einer kleinen GPS-Maus oder wie man die Dinger nennt. Das wäre schon okay, das machen sie ja zurzeit nicht.
Das werden sie aber nicht machen, weil das ist Gebimsel und Gebimsel ist einfach nicht das Prinzip des iPhones. Es funktioniert nicht.
Außer sie wollen die 30 Dollar selber einnehmen und sie bringen selber einen GPS-Maus raus.
Also das ist doch nicht ernsthaft mit deinem iPhone noch so ein Teil rumschleppen.
Na, wenn viele sagen, sie brauchen es nicht.
Da hast du dann auch nochmal Akku-Problem und so weiter und dann musst du das pairen und dann zieht sich das nicht. Das ist sowas für Apple.
Da sind sich dann 188 Kisten Club-Maske gelegt, damit die Zeit nochmal kommt.
Wir wollten ja nicht so viel über das iPhone reden.
Nee, aber es könnte sein. Wir wollten über die WWDC reden und was dort kommt.
Aber wir probieren gerade so ein bisschen, was zu machen, was nicht möglich ist, weil WWDC oder iPhone ist mehr, oder?
Die Frage ist aber, was passiert mit Mac OS X? Weil das ist jetzt die dritte WWDC, wo Leopard das Thema ist.
Wäre. Ist. Wäre.
Wie wäre?
Wissen wir ja noch nicht.
Achso, naja, gut, also...
Vielleicht kommt ja doch 10.6.
Damit würden sie aber komplett die Aufmerksamkeit von iPhone-Development wegnehmen.
Es gibt derzeit keinen 10.6.
Niemand wartet da drauf.
Wenn die sagen, das Apple Quatsch iPhone 2.0 ist schon 10.6-based.
Es gibt genug Sachen bei Leopard, die die Leute nicht benutzen. Die müssen ihre Developer noch ganz schön einschwören auf Leopard. Hier, zum Beispiel Time Machine, ja. Da gibt es einen API dafür, dass Programme das in eigenes User-Interface präsentieren, so wie das Adressbuch das macht. Ich kenne keine einzige Anwendung auf Mac, die auch nur angekündigt hat, sowas zu bieten.
Kennt jemand von euch?
Kennt ihr eine?
Das schöne Programm Delicious Library, was eines der Vorführprogramme auf dem Mac ist. Davon kann man sicher seit gestern, glaube ich, die Beta-Version der Version 2.0 runterladen. Echt?
Gleich mal gucken.
Und wenn man die startet, dann kommt eine Warnung. Achtung, Achtung, wir haben hier mal die Beschleunigung ausgeschaltet. Bitte lad doch mal 10.5.3 runter.
Wie die Beschleunigung ausgeschaltet?
Weil bestimmte visuelle Effekte sind erst möglich mit 10.5.3, offensichtlich mit Delicious Library 2.
Hast du 10.5.3 noch nicht installiert?
Ich hab 10.5.3 noch nicht installiert, weil es das noch nicht gibt.
Na klar, hast du aber vorher rausgekommen. War nur ein Spaß.
Das kommt auch erst zu WWDC. Was steht hier?
Warte mal kurz auf.
Ich glaube, es ist schon in den Startlöchern.
Ja, es ist ein Startlöchern, aber es kommt erst ein, zwei Tage vorher raus. Das machen sie nämlich deshalb, weil die ganzen Developer jetzt noch ihre Lieblingsbugs haben.
Die dann alle schnell gefixt werden.
Die werden zwei Tage vorher gefixt, damit sie das Maul halten.
Damit sie die neuen noch nicht entdeckt haben. Es kann sein, haben die schon mal.
Und wir brauchen kritische Grafik-System-Updates in Mac OS 10.5.3. Das heißt, 10.5.3 wird Kritische Grafik-System-Updates bringen.
Geil, meine ich, World of Warcraft wird ein Stückchen schneller.
Ja, da wird wieder irgendwas funktionieren, was derzeit nicht funktioniert.
Die arbeiten auch ganz streng zusammen, das sieht man immer. Weil die sind nämlich auch so, kommt ein Update raus, kommt gleich ein neues World of Warcraft-Binary mit, irgendwie nutzt die Features aus. Zum Beispiel dieses Multithreaded OpenGL, da war ja World of Warcraft auch gleich als erstes irgendwie vorne dabei. Und haben sie ja von Apple sogar auch gefeatured, das haben sie ja vorgeführt mit den Frames.
Delicious Library, benutzt du das eigentlich oder guckst du das nur so an aus Spaß?
Ich guck mir das nur an aus Spaß. Ich benutze das eigentlich nie, um ehrlich zu sein. Ich kann nur eingeschränkt einen Sinn darin finden, meine Produkte auf virtuellen Regalen zu sehen. Es macht viel her und sieht ganz hübsch aus.
Das ist ja der Programmierer von dem Delicious Library, ist ja ein ehemaliger...
Omniprogrammer.
Wie heißt die? Omnigroup-Programmierer, Will Chipley. Und der hat es auf jeden Fall drauf, weil der macht das ja auch schon seit der Mutter Milch trinkt. Nee, aber seit Anfang an.
Der weiß Bescheid auf jeden Fall, das merkt man.
Und aber er hatte auch irgendwie einen jungen Programmierer bei sich, der aber jetzt gegangen ist und zwar, weil er halt von Apple abgeworben wurde. Ach echt? Ich weiß nicht, wie er hieß. Der hatte ja irgendwie einen und der meinte auch, er hat ihm auch gesagt, dass er dann halt zu Apple gehen soll, dass er die Chance nutzen soll. Und ich weiß aber jetzt hab vergessen, in welcher Abteilung er bei Apple gelandet ist. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr spannende gewesen.
Also Delicious Library ist ja ein Programm, das viele Leute begeistert. Ich kenne aber jetzt auch niemanden, der es benutzt.
Also begeistert sind, ich glaube, die haben noch vor der Vorstellung von 10,5 haben die schon den Best of Show Award, obwohl es Delicious Library noch nicht mal gab, bekommen. Also ich glaube, das war das erste Mal, dass von Apple ein Programm, also auf der Macworld hat das einen Preis gewonnen, obwohl das Programm noch lange nicht verfügbar war mit Delicious Library 1.5 oder irgendwie sowas.
Also das Hauptfeature damals war ja...
Warst du denn diese Bete her auf der Webseite?
Auf der Webseite ist sie nicht, ich schick mal kurz...
Das Hauptfeature damals war doch, als es rauskam, dass man mit der iSight den ISBN-Code von einem Buch scannen konnte und das Delicious Library wusste gleich Bescheid, ne?
Genau. Jetzt weiß ich auch wieder, warum es für mich nicht interessant war. Die Hälfte von dem, was ich im Regal hatte...
Kannte es nicht.
Kannte es nicht, weil es benutzt irgendwie Amazon und ich hab einfach nur so einen Amazon-Tool.
Aber die Zeiten ändern sich ja. Da müsste man jetzt nochmal probieren, weil Amazon... Ist ja schon jetzt wieder ein paar Jahre altes Tool, oder?
Ich werd das mal ausprobieren mit Version 2.
Aber was ich jetzt nochmal kurz reinquatschen muss, während ihr noch so ein bisschen rumsurft, ich hab gerade per Zufall entdeckt, dass es von dem Darwin Streaming Server, also mit dem man halt so Livestreams machen kann und so, gibt's in einer neuen Version, den Source Code, nämlich 603, wo es vorher immer nur 5.5 gab, schon seit 2, 3 Jahren oder so, ist bei denen nichts passiert und alle regen sich schon auf und wollen irgendwie einen Fork machen, weil Apple da nicht aus Tasche kommt. Und jetzt plötzlich aus dem Nichts ist eine neue Version da.
Von? Sorry, ich hab es gerade kurz...
Von dem Darwin Streaming Server. Das heißt, ich werd demnächst mich mal wieder damit schiffen.
Was ist da neu?
Ich hab noch nicht reingeholt, ich hab noch nichts gefunden, wo irgendwie was zu Release Notes steht, aber ich muss da mal gucken.
Tim, kann ich dir irgendwie einen Link zuschicken lassen zu diesem Delicious Library außer per Mail? Haben wir noch ein paar aktuelle Übertragungswege?
Den Link könnt ihr dann auch gleich für all unsere Hörer wieder machen.
By the way, hat von euch jemand schon mal... Also ich benutze ja jetzt iChat wieder, nachdem ich vorher Adium benutzt habe.
Ja, aber da hast du auch keine Security.
Da hab ich keine Security. Dieses OTR, das funktioniert auch nur theoretisch.
Nee, es funktioniert voll toll.
Das macht praktisch aber eine Menge Ärger.
Aber wie wollen wir dann unsere berühmt-berüchtigten Porngespräche führen, die doch privat sind? Ach komm, ich hör die nicht.
Dann müssen wir halt wie früher im Buchkod einander reden. Wie auch immer. Ich hatte einfach von ein paar Sachen die Schnauze voll. Zum Beispiel, dass Falltransfers irgendwie mit Adium nicht funktionieren, was früher mit iChat immer ging. Nur, da ich keinen AEM-Account habe, weil irgendwie AEM irgendwann mal beschlossen hat, dass mein Account jetzt scheiße ist und ich auch nicht mehr mein Passwort ändern kann und überhaupt nicht komme da nicht mehr ran. Da habe ich irgendwann gesagt, fuck you, ich benutze ihn nicht mehr, ich mache jetzt nur noch Java, aber ich schaffe über Java nicht eine Datei zu übertragen über iChat. Und meine Frage ist, warum? Und vielleicht auch mal die Frage an die Hörer. Na, weil hinter einem Nutt sitzt. Was hat das mit Nutt zu tun?
Na, weil beide hinter einem Nutt sitzen.
Ja, das ist bei AEM nicht anders. Dafür hat Apple seine Server, die irgendwie das Nutt umgehen. Und wenn iChat das für AEM macht, dann kann er das auch für Java machen.
Wo du die Datei dann über den Server schickst, weil der den Port offen hat?
Das funktioniert so. Die haben halt diesen Server in der Mitte und beide Clients connecten da dann hin, sodass der und übertragen ihre lokale IP-Adresse mit. Und dann sieht der halt sowohl deren lokale IP-Adresse, als auch die externe IP-Adresse. Und dann geht es eben davon aus. Dass jetzt sind wir gleich bei dem Thema Nut-Traversal. Wollen wir das jetzt vertiefen?
Ja, wenn das die Leute nicht haben, dann geht es nicht. Deswegen schicken die bei OL die Datei über den Server. Der Server nimmt die an und der andere holt sich die von dem Server ab, was bei Java nicht geht. Also vielleicht geht es, aber dann müssten die Java Server diese Traffic Load haben und das...
Aber ich verstehe das jetzt so fernlich, als dass ich hier eine Apple Time Capsule als Router habe. Ich benutze iChat. Apple hat NUT-PMP erfunden. Apple hat NUT-PMP in jedes fucking Protokoll und in ihr OS X eingebaut. Warum benutzen sie das hier nicht?
Weil ich habe aber nicht ihr eigenes Protokoll.
Darf ich mal kurz dazwischen gehen? Kann ich mal ganz kurz dazwischen gehen?
Na vielleicht ist das so.
Das eigentlich Absurde daran ist, dass Videotelefonie ganz selbstverständlich geht und auch Telefonie und diese ganzen Möglichkeiten. Das einzige, was tatsächlich nicht funktioniert, ist wirklich diese blöde Dateiübertragung.
Das ist genau das Argument. Video funktioniert doch auch. Audio funktioniert doch auch. Wenn ich nicht in der Lage bin, komplette Videostreams zu übertragen, warum bin ich da nicht in der Lage, eine kleine PDF-Datei zu übertragen?
Aber das kann doch Adium auch nicht.
Jetzt hast du keine Mate mehr oder was?
Jetzt hab ich gerade nichts mehr zu trinken.
Dann muss ich dir eine Mate holen.
Ich will keine, danke.
Max ist kurz weg.
Ihr könnt endlich über mich reden. Ich hör's mir nachher eh nicht wieder an.
Letzte Ausgabe hast du doch gehört, hast du gesagt.
Genau, ich hab mir mal eine angehört. Und wie war's? Ich war ein bisschen entsetzt, dass es ohne Bild ist. Ich dachte, man könnte sehen, wie unglaublich heiß wir alle sind.
Was hast du zu Hause für einen Server? Du hast doch einen Linux, oder? Hatst du einen Debian?
Das ist ein Debian.
Geht nicht mal eine Maat holen.
Darüber müssen wir auch noch reden. Wir müssen über so viele Sachen reden. Das wird ein langer Podcast heute. Das wird ein langer Podcast. Wir werden auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Minuten dranhängen müssen.
Gut, dass ihr meinen Namen nicht kennt.
Hol dir mal eine Maate. Oh Mann.
Wollen wir mal den Rechner von dem Max hacken?
Meist hat er seine Schlüssel noch nicht aktualisiert. Wahrscheinlich. Darüber müssen wir eigentlich wirklich mal reden. Aber ich hab immer die ganze Zeit Angst, dass wir die Themen bei 80% verlassen. Bist du gerade noch auf der Spur? Wir haben über iChat geredet. Ich hab geflucht, warum meine Dateitransfers über Java nicht funktionieren.
Meine funktionieren über Adium nicht.
Bei Adium hat es noch nie funktioniert.
Doch, im Lokalen geht's.
Ich hab noch nicht ein einziges Mal eine Datei übertragen mit Java-Accounts.
Doch, so lokal, jetzt wird's klappen.
Wie auch immer. Ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, dass mir Adium schon eine Datei auf die Platte gelegt hat.
Dann können wir File übertragen mit Instant Messaging in den Heiligen Gral von Fax und Scanner mit aufnehmen. Das geht einfach nicht.
Auf dem Mac mal so. Na ja, mein Scannen geht ja jetzt hier wieder.
Ja, es geht schon, aber es ist alles nun nicht schön.
Nee, schön ist es nicht. Oh man, jetzt lass mal nicht so viele Dinge aufmachen. Also, iChat, aber warum hab ich denn das überhaupt erwähnt?
Du hast gesagt, du hast ja in letzter Zeit von Adium zurück zu iChat.
Na, das weiß ich nicht, ob wir das Thema jetzt noch unterbringen, aber wir wollten da auf jeden Fall noch mal drüber reden, über dieses Nut-Traversal-Gespräch. Hat man schon. Hatten wir schon, nein, hatten wir nicht. Wir haben nur immer darüber geredet, dass wir es mal haben wollen. Ich hab das hier noch auf meiner Liste, das hat keinen Haken, also haben wir nicht drüber geredet.
Mir war so, als hättest du es schon mal ganz doll erklärt hast.
Ich hab schon mehrfach versucht, im Vorfeld der Sendung mit euch darüber Einigkeit zu erzielen, ob wir darüber immer reden wollen, aber es ist ja nicht so einfach mit euch im Vorfeld der Sendung über irgendetwas Einigkeit zu erzielen. Wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Du bist halt ein schlechter Chef.
Ich bin überhaupt hier gar kein Chef. Wie auch immer. Du hast einen Debian-Server?
Ich hab einen Debian-Server.
Du weißt, dass du ein Problem hast?
Ich weiß, dass ich theoretisch ein Problem habe.
Wie theoretisch? Hast du das immer noch?
Ich hab sämtliche Updates eingespielt, aber ich hab mich noch nicht darum gekümmert, dass ich einen neuen Schlüssel generiere. Das heißt, ich bin theoretisch verwundbar.
Du bist nicht nur theoretisch verwundbar.
Ich bin auch sehr praktisch verwundbar.
Extrem praktisch. Denn beim Debian-Projekt, wir müssen es jetzt mal erzählen, weil es zwar Linux ist, aber es betrifft auch andere. Ja, was ist denn genau passiert?
Oh, jetzt müssen wir ja weit ausholen. Ich hab mal ein bisschen geforscht. Ich bin ja sonst der Unvorbereitete und erzähl immer aus meinem, was ich gerade so im Kopf hab. Und diesmal hab ich auch ein ganz bisschen nachgeguckt, damit ich nicht so viel Blödsinn erzähle. Und zwar, im April 2006 wurde bei Debian ein Patch eingespielt in die Open-SSL-Sourcen.
Also Debian ist eine Linux-Distribution. Es gibt viel Linux. Debian ist eigentlich die Hardcore-Linux-Distribution von den Leuten, die es mit ihrer ganzen Freiheit so genau nehmen, dass sie sich sogar mit anderen Open-Source-Projekten regelmäßig anlegen.
Die sogar irgendwie rumzicken, wenn ihnen irgendein Name nicht passt und dann umbenennt, weil es sonst nicht in ihre Distribution geht.
Das sind die Katholiken unter den Linux-Benutzern.
Ist egal. Auf jeden Fall ist OpenSSL nicht Teil von Debian, sondern Teil mehr von den OpenBSD-Jungs. Aber eigentlich schon was Eigenständiges. Es gibt eigentlich auch keine US, wo es nicht dabei ist. Also Mac OS X hat ja auch ein OpenSSL mit dabei. Man linkt das gegen seine Programme. Es gibt auch Tools, die man direkt benutzen kann. Jedenfalls gab es viele Leute, die auch ihre Programme gegen OpenSSL gelinkt haben. Dazu gehörten zum Beispiel auch SSH oder PGP. PGP weiß ich nicht, aber GPG, wohl die benutzen, glaube ich, was eigenes. Es ist egal. Jedenfalls SSH zum Beispiel benutzt es. SSH ist sehr wichtig. Und jedenfalls die Programmierer, die haben sich, hatten Probleme beim Debuggen ihrer eigenen Software. Weil da gibt es so ein Tool, das heißt Wellgrind oder Wahlgrind. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das genau spricht. Und damit kann man so eine Art Protokoll führen, was das Programm an Speicher alloziert und wieder freigebt. Weil das Wahlgrind hat so eine Art Liste und kann genau sehen, alles klar, das wurde geholt und das wurde freigeben und dann kann man am Ende sehen, ob auch wirklich alles wieder freigegeben wurde, was geholt wurde und ob nicht irgendwie schon auf was zugegriffen wurde, was schon längst abgegeben wurde oder ob auf irgendwas zugegriffen wurde, bevor es alloziert wurde und so weiter. Also der passt ein bisschen auf so eine Art Memory Guard. Und die Developer, die ihr Programm gegen OpenSSL gelingt haben, die hatten ein Problem, weil der Valgrind immer meinte, da würde auf uninitialisierten Speicher zugegriffen. Und das hat halt genervt und gestört beim Debaken ihrer Programme, weil es hat das irgendwie sehr kompliziert gemacht. Und da kamen sie dann auf die Idee, dass sie da was umpatchen und eine Routine, also einen Funktionsaufruf entfernen, der diesen uninitialisierten Speicheraufruf macht. Und dann haben sie sogar auf der Open-SSL-Liste nachgefragt. Sie sind da wohl nicht so auf der richtigen landet. Ich kann es nicht ganz genau erzählen, weil es war auch relativ kompliziert. Deswegen ist der Fuck-Up ja erst entstanden. Sie haben wohl auf der falschen Liste nachgefragt und sie haben gefragt, ob es okay ist, das rauszunehmen, wenn man diese Wellgrind-Fehlermeldung nicht mehr haben möchte. Und da meinten die Open-SSL-Jungs wohl, ja, das könnte er machen, dann kommt er halt nicht mehr. So. Die wussten halt nicht genau, dass es dann am Ende so in der Distribution von Debian landet. Sonst hätten sie wahrscheinlich gesagt, um Gottes Willen nehmt ihr das ja nicht raus, weiß man nicht gut.
Also die haben so gefragt, ob man das überhaupt mal so rausnehmen könnte, um diese Fehlermeldung wegzukriegen, aber nicht als dauerhafte Änderung.
Wahrscheinlich. So nehme ich es an, wird es passiert sein. Und dann ging es auch noch darum, dass es irgendwie in zwei Files irgendwie drin war, so zum Debuggen und nicht, also read.h oder.c hieß es irgendwie oder so, was Ähnliches. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr. Und diese Datei ist dann außersehen in der Distri gelandet und so wurde dann da das OpenSSL gebaut. Irgendwie. Das ist, glaube ich, mehrere kleine Fack-Apps, die insgesamt einen großen ergeben.
Seit einigen Jahren, oder?
Seit April 2006. Und die Sache ist die, dass dieser Aufruf sorgt dafür, dass die Routine, die Zufallsdaten erstellt, die sogenannte Entropie, dass die mit wirklichem, na wirklich ist übertrieben, aber dass die mit Zufall gefüttert wird, weil der Computer kennt halt keinen Zufall, wenn der, egal wie kompliziert die Routine ist, man kann die immer nachvollziehen, man kann das Ergebnis vorhersagen, außer man weiß nicht, womit die Routine gefüttert wurde. So und da wird halt zu, in diesem Fall wurde uninitialisiert das Speicher benutzt auf den Zugriff. Das heißt, irgendein Adressbereich wurde genommen, da wurde der Speicher ausgelesen, weil man ja nicht so richtig wissen konnte, was irgendwie da drin ist. Und wurde durcheinandergewürfelt, so dass am Ende Zufall rauskommt. Natürlich war es nicht nur der uninitialisierte Speicher, sondern zusätzlich wurde noch die Prozess-ID des Programms mit reingenommen, was bei Debian zwischen 1 und 32.767 ist die Null, das ist für den Kernel weg. Und die 68, also 32.768, war für irgendwie was anderes, deswegen 32.767 Möglichkeiten, die wurden mit in die Zufallsroutine eingebunden, so dass jetzt diesen Aufruf, der den uninitialisierten Speichern noch mit reinbringt, der schon weniger vorhersagbar ist als unsere 32.000 Zahlen, blieben nur die 32.000 Zahlen übrig. Das Ergebnis von dem Ganzen ist, dass wenn man zum Beispiel sich ein SSH-Key generiert, was jedes Mal beim Rechner neu installieren passiert, weil man braucht erstmal ein Host-Key bei SSH, dann wurde der Key mit einem Zufall von 37.000, 32.000 verschiedenen Zahlen erzeugt. Das heißt, es gibt bei Debian nur 32.000 verschiedene Host-Keys.
Und das ist nicht viel.
Das ist nicht viel. Es hat auch nur zwei, drei Tage dauert oder wahrscheinlich initial nur ein paar Stunden, bis die ersten Tools aufkamen, die ganz schnell diese Keys in einer großen List-Date, nämlich nachgeneriert, wurden. Weil sie brauchten ja nur noch die Zufall-Routine benutzen, die 32.000 Zahlen eine nach der anderen durchjagen mit einer Schleife. Und dann hatten sie alle 32.000 Keys. Und dann gab es wieder Tools, die die Server abscannen, wo denn die passenden Schlüssel sitzen und haben die halt irgendwie aufgemacht. Das ging ganz flott.
Sicher, dass das nur 32.000 sind, weil die Blacklist allein ist ja...
Die Blacklist ist ein bisschen größer, weil es gibt ja nicht nur SSH-Keys, sondern auch andere Keys und dann kommt es auch noch drauf an, ob du einen 1024-Bit-Key hast oder einen 4096-Key oder 2048, deswegen sind es ein paar mehr. Und ich glaube, außer der Process ID war noch irgendwie die Rechenarchitektur mit drin, also ob es irgendwie 32-Bit ist oder 64-Bit, deswegen war es irgendwie noch dreimal mehr als 32.000. Aber das haben die alles ausgerechnet, weil für die ist natürlich unter einer Million gar nichts, das ist halt sehr vorhersagbar. Hätten sie diesen uninitialisierten Speicheraufruf mit drin gelassen, wäre es wahrscheinlich das Millionenfache gewesen, und dann könnte man diese Liste nicht mehr erstellen. Also die müssen jetzt schon für so eine Attacke so ein paar tausend Request pro Sekunde rausballern, um irgendwie den richtigen zu erwischen. Und wären es noch mehr gewesen, dann wäre es halt schon nicht mehr so einfach möglich gewesen.
Mit anderen Worten, um es mal ein bisschen einfacher zusammenzufassen, seit zwei Jahren ist in dem Linux. Was eigentlich so ein bisschen der heilige Gral der Linux-Distributionen ist, wo auch ganz viele extrem populäre Sachen wie Ubuntu zum Beispiel drauf basieren, war ein Fehler drin, der sozusagen die Sicherheit von allen SSH-Keys zum Connecten usw.
Und nicht nur SSH, sondern auch noch viele andere Sachen, die halt diese Zufallsroutinen benutzen.
Auch SSL-Keys für den Webbrowser, Zertifikate. Also eigentlich alles, was so heutzutage die Sicherheit eines Server-Systems definiert, ist eigentlich keine Sicherheit mehr vorhanden. Seit zwei Jahren.
Und das Problem an der Sache ist noch, dass wenn jemand schon, sagen wir mal, 2007, von dir eine verschlüsselte Kommunikation mitgeschnitten hat, dann kann er sie jetzt auch nachträglich entschlüsseln. Das ist das eigentliche Gefährliche daran. Das ist die sogenannte Offline-Attacke, glaube ich. Das machen sie auch nachträglich noch irgendwie.
Wie das so ist, wenn du den Schlüssel hast, dann hast du den Schlüssel. Vor allem, wie lange dauert es bis jetzt irgendwie? Ich meine, das bedeutet, wenn heute einer einen Server betreibt, der unter Debian läuft, oder wenn du auch nur auf dem Debian deinen SSH-Key erzeugt hast und du weißt gar nicht, dass das in dem Moment ein Debian-System war. Ich habe jetzt eben auch schon über Nacht gedacht, wo habe ich eigentlich meinen SSH-Key erzeugt, aber ich glaube, das war auf dem Mac. Dann ist einfach mal Polen offen. Da musst du einfach jetzt mal wirklich zusehen, dass du alle deine Keys ausgetauscht bekommst.
Aber so schnell, wie auch die Exploit-Tools rauskamen, kamen auch die Tools raus, die das überprüfen und angeblich auch in irgendwelchen Open-SSH-Versionen wird gecheckt, ob du eventuell einen Host-Key hast, der in dieser Liste mit drin ist. Und dann sagt der gleich, nee, benutze ich nicht, der ist irgendwie evil. Da entsteht immer gleich eine Infrastruktur vom Feinsten. Da rasseln nur die kleinen Tools hoch.
Aber auf dem Mac ist da jetzt noch nichts passiert. Es gab ja seitdem, dass rausgekommen ist, noch kein Software-Update.
Nee, das betrifft den Mac ja auch nicht.
Passiv betrifft es ihn auch.
Was meinst du mit, da sind jetzt Tools drin, die...
Ach so, bei Debian wahrscheinlich. Mir ist doch egal, was die anderen machen.
Auf welcher Ebene greifen denn diese Tools?
Na, wenn du auf einem Debian das OpenSSH installierst. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab auch bei dem OpenSSH-Jungs geguckt. Da sieht man nichts von Update. Ich denke mal, das sind spezielle Versionen, die man da benutzen kann.
Aber es ist ein ganz spezifischer Debian-Fuck-Up. Es ist nichts, was mit OpenSSH als solchen zu tun hat.
Die OpenSSH-Jungs haben auch nichts falsch gemacht. Also die bieten ja so eine Art Paket an. Die Debian-Typen nehmen dieses Paket, integrieren es in iOS und haben da halt Änderungen dran vorgenommen. Diese Änderung hat halt nur Debian vorgenommen. Deswegen ist dieser Fehler auch nur bei Debian und zum Beispiel nicht bei Suze oder so was.
Aber Moment mal, Moment mal, Moment mal. Wenn ich jetzt einen Key generiere auf einem Debian-System und spätestens wenn ich den dann auf Suze übertrage, habe ich da genau das gleiche Problem.
Weil der Key ist der bekannteste.
Wenn ich einen Public Key generiere auf einem Debian-System und den dann zum Beispiel auf meinem Mac OS X Server eintrage, weil ich zum Beispiel jemanden, der Ubuntu hat, von außen SSH Zugang geben will, dann ist doch auch mein Mac OS X kompromittiert, oder?
Ja, der User kann rein und weil andere Leute den Secret Key von diesem User nachmachen könnten, könnten dann auch andere Leute rein.
Mit anderen Worten, das mag zwar sein, dass der Fehler nur in Debian aufgetreten ist, aber betroffen sind doch davon wirklich alle.
Genau, also wenn auch du auf deinem Mac Server oder Mac überhaupt anderer Leute Keys eingetragen hast, und das ist halt ein Key, der in den letzten zwei Jahren unter auf dem Debian-System erzeugt wurde, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass einer von diesen 32.767 Keys ist, sehr hoch.
Genau, und insofern gefährdet das die Security überhaupt. Ist mir doch wurscht, was die anderen machen.
Ich hab keine Debian User auf meinem Rechner.
Ja gut, aber das ist nicht so unwahrscheinlich jetzt.
Aber wie sieht es denn aus, ob nicht jemand zum Beispiel probiert von einem Debian-System, den Fingerprint nachfertigen kann oder sowas auf dieser Art und Weise?
Ich meine, es ist gut, aber die Keys sind bekannt. Man bräuchte im Prinzip Tools, mit denen man so Sachen wie Authorized Keys, Files checkt, genau, gibt's. Indem man halt einfach automatisch nach genau diesen Keys sucht und guckt, ob die irgendwo rumliegen. Weil das ist ja nicht so eine Attacke, die man irgendwie ausnutzen kann unter bestimmten Bedingungen, sondern hier geht's wirklich um exakt benannte, deutlich klar als solche zu erkennende Keys, die man eben nur, man muss nur wissen, wo man nach ihnen schaut. So, und dann kann man halt die Zertifikate und die Keys aus irgendwelchen Keyrings einfach raus schießen.
Also man braucht nur bei Google OpenSSL und Bug oder Debian eigentlich eben und dann kriegt man die Seiten.
Insofern wäre das eigentlich, was Apple auch in ein Softwareupdate packen könnte.
Dass die auch die Keys gleich erkennen?
Ja, dass sie einfach ein Tool bieten, was einfach alle Orte, wo solche Keys abgelegt sind. Das ist zum Beispiel die Keychain. Ja, aufs Herz und so. Ja, dass du einfach so ein kleines Tool hast, was du mal startest und das sagt, irgendwie check all Keychains so auf dem System. Geht einfach durch dein ganzes System, checkt alle Keychains und die anderen üblichen verdächtigen Orte und sagt, hier ist ein vulnerable Key und bitte nicht mehr.
Also ich meine zumindest für Administratoren wäre es ein schönes Werkzeug.
Müsstest du mal gucken, wahrscheinlich gibt es das sogar auch schon. Ist ja am Ende nur so ein Schälske, was man sich bei den Debianisten herunter holen kann.
Ja gut, aber du musst ja auch wissen, wo diese Keys sind. Und gerade wenn es in Keychains ist, ist es natürlich jetzt nicht so ohne Weiteres.
Die auch noch verschlüsselt sind.
Ich finde, das ist schon etwas, was ein Betriebssystem pro Weile mal, damit könnten sich auf jeden Fall eine Menge Freunde machen.
Auf jeden Fall die super sichere SSH-Verschlüsselung ist jetzt erstmal flöten.
Quasi.
Bei dir.
Bei mir zum Beispiel. Ja, aber nicht nur bei mir.
Wann hast du dein Rechner aufgesetzt?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Kann durchaus sein, dass das vor April 2006 war.
Nein, nicht Spreeblick.
Da hab ich schon, da ist schon neuer generiert. Bei meinem Home-Server ist es noch nicht.
Tja, mit der Verschlüsselung. Da können wir jetzt auch mal gleich überleiten auf ein anderes Problem. Und das betrifft aber dann wiederum den Macintosh. Wir hatten die Diskussion bei Mobile Macs im Blog. Ich hab dieses Thema auch schon länger hier auf meiner Liste gehabt für den Podcast. Aber ich hab's da neulich einfach mal angesprochen. GPG Mail. Die Integration der Open Source GPG Verschlüsselungslösung für E-Mail, die das Ganze in MailApp integriert, das funktionierte nicht mehr mit dem Aufkommen von MailApp in Leopard. Also man hat Leopard installiert und das neue Mail konnte dann mit diesem Plug-in nichts mehr anfangen. Es funktionierte einfach nicht. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass man eben, wenn man vorher darauf gesetzt hat, auf einmal kein freies PGP mehr hatte. Man könnte sich natürlich nach wie vor PGP kaufen, aber das war es mir noch nie wert. Ich weiß nicht, hat das jemand von euch schon mal gemacht oder benutzt? Ich hab das früher unter Mac OS neunmal eine Weile benutzt.
Ich hätte es eventuell gekauft, aber es ist ja nur eine Subscription und wenn man es kauft, hält es nur für ein Jahr.
Das ist nämlich der Hauptgrund, warum ich das nicht mache. Also das Kaufen, damit könnte ich ja irgendwie noch leben, aber so Subscription ist einfach nicht mein Ding. Weil dann lohnt es sich auch wirklich nur, wenn du es am Laufen im Meter irgendwie, also wenn du wirklich da so kritisch drauf basierst. Und weißte gar ja, so Security Software, die aus-timed ist, aber man hat jetzt im Prinzip den gleichen Effekt, wie wenn man es aus-timed, indem man einfach ein Software-Update einspielt und es nicht hinterherkommt. Das Problem ist, dass derjenige, der dir das bereitgestellt hat, das Ding war schon immer ziemlich buggy, aber es konnte zumindest so das Minimum. Ja, das GPG-Mail, dieses Plug-In für Mail ab. Das war schon immer ziemlich buggy. Das hat mich total genervt, weil zum Beispiel, wenn man so bestimmte Options angeklickt hat, somit automatisch auspacken und so, führt dir das dazu, wenn du einen IMAP-Server hast, dass dann die ganze Zeit deine Mails wieder von Red auf Unread zurückgekippt sind. Das hat mich wahnsinnig gemacht. Und ich hab die erste Zeit gesucht, was das Problem war.
Wie funktioniert das eigentlich? Benutzen die auch diese Input-Plugins, die man auch bei Safari benutzt?
Das ist ein richtiges Mail-Ab-Plugin. So ein Bande, nicht als Input-Manager oder so.
Genau, das mein ich.
Das taucht so richtig auch in den Mail-Preferences, hat so seine eigene User-Interface. Insofern ist es auch ganz gut. Ich würde nicht sagen, es ist das Beste, was es je gab. Aber die Integration war zumindest so ausreichend, dass man eben für seinen PGP, GPG-Bedarf, also verschlüsselte E-Mail sozusagen, dass man damit arbeiten konnte. Wie auch immer. Nachdem dann bekannt war, dass das nicht funktionierte unter Leopard, wurde eine baldige Lösung angekündigt auf der Webseite. Es kam dann auch einige Wochen später eine Beta-Version, die bei mir allerdings nie funktionierte. Aber jetzt seit einem Monat gibt es eine Version, die habe ich neulich entdeckt, die halt diese Hauptprobleme irgendwie behebt. Es funktionierte sozusagen überhaupt. Ich bin also jetzt auf dem Status, wo ich vorher war, dass ich eben GPG wieder benutzen kann. Ja, soweit so schlecht. Tatsache ist, seit gestern gibt es eine neue Version.
Steht hier, 25. Mai.
Das ist dann jetzt noch neuer, als ich bisher zur Kenntnis genommen habe.
D53.
Aha, okay, dann kann ich dann gleich mal aktualisieren.
Die Adresse ist www.sente.ch.
25 ist da, okay, das ist eine neue Version, die D53. Ich glaube, ich hatte die D52. Leider schreibt er auch immer nicht, was neu ist. Das ist alles so ein bisschen komisch.
Steht noch oben drüber, dass es noch nicht läuft und unten drunter steht dann der Link zum Download.
Hier gibt es Release Notes, warte mal. Release Notes ist halt nicht für diese Beta, das ist nur für die V46. Also das ist irgendwie alles ein bisschen komisch. Auch diese ganzen Screenshots sind irgendwie noch von 10.2.
Das gibt's schon ewig, ich hab's ganz früh auch mal gehabt. Irgendwie war's mir zu blöd und hab's gelassen.
Aber es fließt halt nicht viel Energie da rein und das ist eben das Dove da dran. Jetzt gab's ja auf unserem Blog die Diskussion darüber, was man denn nun verwenden sollte. Dann kam dann auch gleich wieder die Geschichte auf mit Verschlüsselung gibt's ja auf dem Mac. Man kann ja Zertifikate benutzen. Und es gibt ja einen Standard, das ist ein S-MIME-Standard, secure MIME, das MIME-Format, blablabla, mit dem man Attachments macht, mit dem deine Mail in mehrere klar mit Typ gekennzeichnete Teile aufgeteilt wird. Darüber gibt es eben eine Spezifikation, wie man verschlüsselt, aber auf Basis von Zertifikaten. Vorteil ist, ist in Mac OS X komplett drin und in Mail.App auch. Das heißt, wenn du dein eigenes Zertifikat in deiner Keychain hast für deine E-Mail-Adresse, dann erkennt Mail.App das automatisch, benutzt es auch und du hast dann eben die entsprechenden Settings in Mail, wenn du deine Mail verschickst, dass es dann irgendwie verschlüsselt ist. Und was ein anderer Vorteil ist von S-Mime ist, wenn ich dir das erste Mal eine verschlüsselte Mail schicke, dann erhältst du meinen Public Key gleich mit. Das heißt, du kannst mir direkt darauf antworten. Anders als bei GPG, wo dieser ganze Key-Austausch nochmal eine separate Geschichte ist, wo du an irgendwelche Key-Server rangehen musst und die runterladen musst und Key-IDs vergleichen musst. Und auch da ist immer alles irgendwie komisch und dann gibt es keine richtigen Tools.
Ich erinnere mich ganz gut.
Und auch dieses GPG-Keychain-Programm zum Beispiel, was ich bisher immer verwendet habe, das startet bei mir gar nicht mit der Leopard. Auch das ist nochmal unkomfortabler geworden. Ich muss also da wieder auf die Kommando-Zeile runter. Das ist noch zu ertragen, aber schön ist es nicht. Wie auch immer, bei S-Mime hast du das einfach mit drin. Nachteil ist, es basiert auf Zertifikaten. Das heißt, es basiert auch auf der Sicherheit von Zertifikaten. Dann hast du wieder das Problem, wo kriegst du ein Zertifikat her?
Ohne viel Geld dafür auszugeben.
Ohne viel Geld dafür ausgeben zu können. Du kannst natürlich dir selber eins machen, aber dann ist es eben nicht unterschrieben von irgendeiner bereits im System vorinstallierten Autorität. Genau das gleiche Problem wie bei Webseiten.
Wir haben letztens schon bequatscht, aber in der vorletzten Sendung weiß ich gar nicht, dass man jetzt die Zerts irgendwie annehmen kann. Das müsste ja dann auch das Mail-Dings betreffen, dass man einfach sagt, okay, ist angenommen, und dann landet es in der Keychain, und ab da ist es dann okay.
Du weißt, wie es ist, wenn man schon verschlüsselt kommuniziert, und das erste, was du von deinem Gegenüber verlangst, ist, hallo, hier kommt etwas Fremdes aus dem Internet, sag ja, dass alles in Zukunft okay ist. Das ist irgendwie nicht so der Grad von Sicherheit, den du haben willst, weil wenn du jetzt ein wirklich bestätigtes, gekaufte Zertifikat benutzt, dann funktioniert das ja out of the box. Dein Gegenüber muss nichts davon wissen, dass du ihm eine verschlüsselte Mail geschickt hast. Die kommt einfach an, sie ist einfach verschlüsselt.
Außerdem steht da auch, ich meine, wie kommt so eine Mail an? Dann kommt immer an, Achtung, diese Mail ist potenziell unsicher, die Identität ist absehend, das konnte nicht festgestellt werden. Und plötzlich haben Leute Angst, obwohl ich ihnen eine sichere Mail geschickt habe, haben sie plötzlich das erste Mal das Gefühl, dass es nicht von mir käme. Und erklär das mal deiner Oma.
Genau, das ist das Problem. Und das ist halt total unschön. In dem Thread bei uns im Blog gab es dann jemanden, jetzt muss ich gerade mal gucken, hier gpg-Mail ab. Da gab es sehr viele Kommentare, da ging es auch so ein bisschen hin und her, da wurde etwas religiös diskutiert. Auf jeden Fall gibt es da jemand, der da gerade einen Guide zusammenbaut. Ich hatte jetzt leider etwas wenig Zeit, mich mit dem Thema da nochmal zu beschäftigen. Da sind auf jeden Fall ein, zwei Links auch gepostet worden in den Kommentaren, wo Tipps dazu sind, wie man eben sich schnell so ein S-Mime-Zertifikat holen kann. Da ist auch so ein Dienst genannt. Ich weiß gar nicht, kennt ihr den? Muss ich gleich mal schauen, weil ich es nämlich vergessen habe. Jetzt gehe ich erstmal auf eine Webseite, wo auch so ein Zertifikat ist, wo man sich selbst signen kann. Ihr habt wahrscheinlich nicht gelesen die Kommentare, oder?
mobilemax.de Wobei, das ist ja das Schöne, wenn man jetzt mal mit Firefox 3 unterwegs ist, wie viele Webseiten von gerade irgendwelchen Open Source-Projekten plötzlich überhaupt nicht mehr gehen, weil Firefox 3 ja wirklich ziemlich penibel ist, was die Überprüfung von Zertifikaten angeht. Und nicht mehr nur noch böse Waren wie Firefox 2 noch oder relativ deutlich darauf hinweist, sondern den Zugriff auf die Seite komplett verweigert. Was ich schonmal eigentlich ziemlich grandios finde, aber es wird noch für einige Projekte dadurch richtig große Probleme geben.
Du findest was gut, das was den Zugriff komplett verweigert.
Nicht Mac OS X, sondern es ist Firefox 3, verweigert den Zugriff auf Webseiten, wo das Zertifikat nicht hinhaut.
Ja.
Erstmal. Und man wird sehr, sehr fett darauf hingewiesen, dass man zwar eine Ausnahme definieren kann, aber dass man das bitte nach Möglichkeit sein lassen solle.
Und das sind einige Applikationen, die darunter fallen. Das ist zum Beispiel auch das beliebte Penta Buff, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Das ist halt einfach das gleiche Problem. Projekte, die kein Geld haben, sich eine Zertifikatinfrastruktur zu leisten.
Aber wie sieht das denn zum Beispiel mit CRZ aus? Warum sind die da nicht in Firefox mit dabei?
CRZ ist halt so ein Ort, wo man sich so relativ leicht so ein Zertifikat klicken kann. Das habe ich auch mal ausprobiert, das funktioniert. Also man kann zu CRZ hingehen, dann macht man sich irgendwie einen Account, dann lässt man sich irgendwie eschuren. Das heißt, man muss sich so einen CRZ-Eschurer suchen und der sagt dann, okay, ich bestätige, dass du bist, der du bist.
Was ja beim CCC überhaupt kein Problem sein dürfte.
Was auch außerhalb des CCC kein Problem ist. Du kriegst diese Schuralisten bei CRZ-Org. So und dann kannst du dir SSL-Zertifikate geben lassen und du kannst dir halt auch E-Mail erst mal Zertifikate geben lassen.
Die hoffentlich nicht auf Debian berechnet worden sind.
Das wär ein Spaß.
Auweia. Darüber habe ich noch gar nicht nachgedacht.
Okay, weiter mit dem Text.
Mal gucken, ob die irgendeine tolle Meldung auf ihrer Webseite haben. Das wär natürlich bitter, ne? Also hier steht jetzt so erstmal nichts davon. Advertising? Der mit Vertising auf ihrer Webseite?
Na irgendwie müssen wir ja ganz ans Schlüsselneuberechnung finanzieren.
Das ist ja mal eine komische Advertising, wie auch immer. Caz, macht ihr das? Wobei ich hab das unter Tiger erfolgreich ausprobiert gehabt. Unter Leopard hatte ich zuletzt Probleme, aber da hatte ich auch wie immer einfach zu wenig Zeit, um das mir nochmal richtig anzuschauen. Grundsätzlich glaube ich, geht das nach wie vor auch problemlos mit Leopard. Aber warum wird nun Caz nicht allgemein anerkannt? Das Problem ist einfach, wenn man sich anschaut, wie dieser Certifizierungsprozess, dieser Assuring-Prozess abläuft. Weißt du, da sind einfach Privatleute unterwegs. Und das ist so ein Web of Trust, man vertraut sich halt einfach, wenn genug Leute gesagt haben, dem vertraue ich und so weiter. Aber das schließt einfach wenig aus. Das ist einfach keine wirklich stringent geführte Organisation, wo regelmäßig und nachhaltig auf die Sicherheit von allem hingewiesen wird. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo das Root-Level-Zertifikat tatsächlich mit Web-Browsern oder sogar Betriebssystemen ausgeliefert wird, wäre diese Infrastruktur so dermaßen beliebt bei Spamern. Also die würden sich da in diesen Assuring-Prozess reinmogeln und sich selber als Assurer assuren lassen und so weiter. Ich glaube, das wäre böse. Das wäre auch wahrscheinlich für diese Community böse. CA Zert ist eigentlich für alles das OK, wo du eben sagst, OK, CA Zert, dem vertraue ich ausreichend. Ja, also das ist für mich irgendwie vertrauenswürdig genug, mir persönlich, weil ich das irgendwie halbwegs einschätzen kann und das Zertifikat dem vertraue ich und allem, was darunter zugelassen ist. Aber ich glaube, wenn das auf die ganze Welt bei Default losgelassen werden würde, dann wäre das im Dokument X tot.
Aber ich bin gerade so ein bisschen am Überlegen, wie könnte denn eine Infrastruktur aussehen, die sicher ist, aber trotzdem bezahlbar? Und wäre das nicht eine schöne Aufgabe für unseren lieben kleinen Überwachungsstaat, dass die Bundesrepublik Deutschland oder besser gleich die EU sich darum kümmert, dass jeder Bürger ein Zertifikat bekommt?
Na ja, das probieren sie ja nun schon so länger und wollen damit ja alle möglichen Dienste und zentralen Speicherungsvorhaben machen, also diese ganzen PKI-Infrastrukturen. Sowas bauen sie ja auch tatsächlich auf und versuchen einem das irgendwie anzudrehen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das so ein empfehlenswerter Vorgang ist.
Wieso nicht, eigentlich?
Weil ein bisschen Chaos mal ganz gut tut.
Weil der Trend... Ein vollelektronischer Start ist meiner Meinung nach nicht wünschenswert. Ja, aber es ist durchaus auch sinnvoll, die Sachen noch so weit zu verzögern, bis die handelnden Personen genug Grundkenntnisse in Computertechnologie und Globalvernetzung haben, dass sie zumindest im Ansatz wissen, wovon sie reden. Aber derzeit haben wir einfach eine Entscheiderebene, die keinerlei digitale Kultur eingeatmet hat. Und das ist einfach nicht schön. Da kommen dann nur so Mammutprojekte bei draußen. Außerdem sind es halt alles potenzielle Überwachungsgeschichten. Und ich meine gerade, das nächste ist dann, wenn du wirklich jetzt sagst, mit deinem Führerschein oder mit deinem Personalausweis kriegst du auch noch gleich dein E-Mail-Zertifikat. Dann geht es los mit irgendwie Schlüsselhinterlegungen. Und dann ist einfach alles, was du verschlüsselst, dann gleich wiederlesbar. Das ist schon, ja, aber weißt du was?
Zwangsläufig, zwangsläufig?
Weil da einfach Begehrlichkeiten da sind. Da kommt dann das BKA vorbei und sagt, jetzt haben wir doch hier gerade mal so, jetzt generieren wir doch gerade mal Zertifikate für unsere Bürger. Wir müssen aber die Sicherheit vor dem Terrorismus sicherstellen und überhaupt.
Das ist doch bei jedem anderen Zertifikat, bei der Privatfirma, die Zertifikate erstellt, ist das doch kein bisschen anders.
Die erstellen das Zertifikat, die unterschreiben es nur für dich. Du erstellst das Zertifikat, schickst es zu denen hin und die unterschreiben und sagen damit, es ist okay.
Aber genau, das könnte der Staat auch machen.
Das könnte der Staat auch machen, aber wo ist da der Unterschied?
Dass es für mich günstiger wird.
Günstiger, wenn eine Bürokratie sich darum kümmert, die irgendwie 50 Jahre braucht, um so ein Projekt durchzuziehen. Ich glaube, das ist günstiger. Wie auch immer. Ich glaube, das Problem kriegen wir jetzt hier auch nicht gelöst und wir kommen jetzt auch so ein bisschen von unserem Kernthemenfeld ab. Tatsache ist, GPG auf dem Mac suckt. Und meine These im Blog war auch, es ist eigentlich schade, dass die Open Source Welt das als nicht notwendig erachtet, auch für eine gute Integration in populäre Betriebssysteme zu sorgen. Warum ist das nicht ein Standardteil des GPG-Projektes?
Ich glaube, das ist nochmal ein besonderes Manko von diesen ganzen Security-Sachen. Ich hab irgendwie immer das Gefühl, dass dieses ganze Sicherheitsbereich soweit auch für mich obskur ist, weil es keine vernünftigen Erklärungen gibt, wie das funktioniert. Das find ich schade.
Das stimmt allerdings. Das ist alles ein bisschen zu kompliziert. Man müsste es ein bisschen eilen.
Es ist auch zu kompliziert. GPG kann man einfach ernsthaft keinem erzählen. Das ist so eine Technologie, wo komplette Bücher dazu geschrieben werden müssen, dass die Leute wissen, wie sie es aufsetzen. Auch die 38. Beschreibung, wie setze ich das auf in irgendwelchen Blogs, die manchmal ganz gut sind, ist einfach schade, dass es nötig ist.
Jetzt hören wir mal ein. Ich hab die ganze Diskussion doch gelesen. Stimmt.
Ja, jetzt haben wir aber schon eine Menge durch. Wir werden auch etwas langatmig und müde, wenn du mich fragst. Wollen wir das uns noch weiter geben oder wollen wir dann alles auf die WWDC vertagen? Wir haben jetzt zwei Stunden fast durch.
Na, dann reicht es ja aber auch mal.
Gibt es noch etwas Wichtiges?
Lass uns beim nächsten Mal noch ein bisschen über Flash-Speicher bis dahin jeder ein bisschen schlau machen.
Ich habe meine Zweifel, dass wir in der nächsten Sendung zu irgendwas anderem kommen werden, außer den frischen Themen, die uns irgendwie auf die Liste gelegt wurden.
Wenn Dennis rechnet.
Wer weiß, vielleicht kommt ja Flash-Speicher-Support auf der WWDC. Weil es macht ja jetzt richtig Spaß, wenn das OS das auch ordentlich integriert, weil nur Flash-Speicher als Festplatte ist ja langweilig. Man braucht es ja ein bisschen als Beschleuniger, als Cache, jetzt gucken wir mal mit großen Augen.
Was für ein Support meinst du denn? Apple liefert bereits Flash-Speicher aus, also? Im MacBook Air.
Genau. Wovon du gerade sprichst, ist glaube ich so dieses Ready-State, oder wie auch immer das heißt, Ready-Boost.
Zum Beispiel.
Dieses, was Microsoft jetzt großartig angekündigt hat.
Ach so, Festplatten, die so ein bisschen Flash haben.
Genau, die haben so ein paar Megabyte.
Ja, aber es ist überhaupt nicht garantiert, dass das wirklich Speed bringt.
Das macht den Rechner eher langsam am Augenblick.
Das ist alles Quatsch.
Das ist ziemlich einfach, genau.
Das ist alles Quatsch. Nun gut, ich denke wir machen dem Podcast jetzt hier ein Ende, der ist eh schon viel zu lang geworden.
ZFS ist vielleicht mal ein Thema auf der WWDC.
Ich hoffe.
Drückt mir alle die Daumen, Jungs.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es auf dem Thema ist.
Wo, wenn nicht da?
Pass auf, mit Thema meine ich alles, was in der Keynote kommt. Das ist Thema.
Ach, in der Keynote.
Alles andere sind Details, die da irgendwie noch veröffentlicht werden.
Die werden allein eine Stunde nur mit der Präsentation von Demo von Applikationen verbringen.
Lasst euch überraschen, man.
Es ist für Developer.
Es wird anders kommen, als wir denken.
Das wollen wir doch alle hoffen. Zumindest haben wir irgendein Secret-Produkt, von dem wir jetzt noch nicht wissen, haben wir nicht vorher gesehen, oder? Wir geben gleich zu, dass wir eigentlich visionslos sind.
Eigentlich haben wir gar keine Ahnung.
Wir haben eigentlich keine Ahnung. Wir plappern immer nur den Rumors hinterher. So sind wir, beim Overmax. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bis in zwei Wochen, plus zwei Tage.
Bis dann haben wir wieder ausgeschlafen.